there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey it's us again okay we are back it's
saturday
we've already started drinking what else
is yeah it's saturday and starting to
get started
[Laughter]
starts still kind of sleepy i gotta try
to up for the weekend
you gotta try to get it you didn't take
an old man nap i tried but i just laid
there and i was listening to the damn
bell [ __ ] talk [ __ ] all right
and here we are we're ready for some
dwight quiet time
and then they just heard that those are
my favorite and i just kind of was like
zoning out but i never actually really
fell asleep
yeah i know that feeling that happens to
me a lot so it's gonna be a good show
there's gonna be a witch trial show
tonight
yeah this actually i was surprised
because i've had this on um
this has been on a couple of the polls
somebody recommended this
case to me like a long time ago and i
apologize i can't remember who it was
and it's so it's been in the box and
it's come up in the polls a couple of
times and it never got any votes
but this time it got like a whole bunch
of votes so i guess like everybody was
kind of like yeah man why not some
witchcraft trial it's a week before
thanksgiving it's
yeah colonial america kind of you know
buckles and [ __ ]
people in buckles and buckles and she
got buckles on the shoes got buckles on
the hats
like the dude that's on the quaker oats
box yeah you know what i mean yeah man
like this is uh
and it was interesting because this is a
case that i
had never heard of and i didn't really
know much about
because it happened like before the
salem wish trials and
had kind of a different outcome and also
famous people involved william penn
himself
adjudicated this [ __ ] trial yeah so
you know i thought that was kind of an
interesting
and actually it's it's weird too because
there's not a huge amount of info on it
like the wikipedia page about this woman
it's really weird because they call it
the margaret matson
witch trial but it was her but it was
another woman too there was two women
that they were trying at the same time
for the same charges
but the other woman like hardly ever
gets mentioned which i was like okay
um but the wikipedia page is maybe like
a paragraph and a half or something like
that
so most of the info that i got from this
was from um
there was this like five page article
that was called the fame of a witch that
was written by this
uh lawyer named craig something i said
it's in my notes somewhere i'll say it
when i get to it slavin slagen something
like that
and uh so there was a lot of information
about it in there and there was like a
couple of articles about it like from
pennsylvania specific
you know historical blogs and [ __ ] like
that so i kind of like tried to piece
together
because i think that what's interesting
about this
case particularly is the way it turned
out
so different than the later salem ones
and like the whole kind of quaker belief
thing and all that kind of stuff i found
that
all really interesting like from a
cultural context so we'll kind of get
into that
a little bit like i said it's a week
before thanksgiving here in the u.s and
this is kind of it's not really
thanksgiving related but it's like
colonial america related maybe that's
why everybody voted for it this week
they're pouring in we're up at 25 now
which that's that's
that's actually a lot for our show
everybody's in here zach's in here
sophie's here ken tammy
and tila's in here ken
there's fourth door down somebody named
cess
hey uh taylor did you see the hand yeah
did you see that he's gonna keep nagging
you until you've seen it
i know uh last time last time we did the
show i was talking about
heavy metal the heavy metal movie and
um the hand yeah and when i was talking
about the heavy metal movie it's it's
like a um
it's an animated movie it's kind of like
creep show where it's much little tails
and has a wrap around
and one of the tales i was trying to
remember what it was called it was
called i found it it was called den
yeah and one of our subscribers sent me
this in a big package i can't remember
his name off the top where the letter
his letter's around here somewhere
yeah i don't remember where i put it out
he's cleaning the other day and i put
the letters like tucked him somewhere
and now i can't find him yeah if you
sent this to me go ahead and drop a
comment yeah it was the same box that
had all those like weird tails and stuff
like that in it
yeah that was um because uh i wanna i
wanna remember what your name is so i
can so i can thank you and everything
but uh
this is one of the stories was this
and going through it real quick it looks
like it might be kind of a
the one that they showed in the movie
might have been a little bit based on
this because some of the characters look
look the same but this was a uh this was
a badass
story it's called the den chronicles or
chronicles of den and
i remembered this as a kid it's it's a
70s thing
and um real well illustrated
all right and everybody in it pretty
much
nude real stocky denzel he's got his
junk hanging out
he's always hung up there's
demonetization yeah
he's always hanging out he's always he's
always hooking up with these
like hot extra dimensional barbarian
princesses and priestesses and stuff
with like some of them look kind of
mayan or aztec headdresses and
monsters and dinosaurs and
but it was just uh and they made a lot
of these
and this is the first book i'll probably
have to get the other ones
i haven't really gone in there and
looked at it it was kind of a conan type
story but uh yeah i'm glad that i got
this
look at that it's some cool [ __ ] yeah
i'm glad that i got this i was talking
about how crazy that font design was
yeah i got to read this there's like
five or six of these and then there's
like
a bunch of spin-offs that are around
this world it's the den chronicles i
don't know why it's called den that's
his name
i guess his name name might be dennis i
don't know
he calls himself dan he goes into
another dimension
he's nerd he's nerdy in this world but
he goes into that dimension and he's uh
just this badass yeah i mean he's
hooking up with all these hot chicks he
can't believe it
i'm just saying he's like heroic like if
i'm thinking about it like i'm
a dork in this um you know
dimension which you know i don't stretch
too far to think of that
but i feel like if i had a nerdy name
like dennis or poindexter or whatever
and then like i magically got
transported to
another dimension where i was like super
buff and awesome
i would think that i would come up with
a better name than just a shortened form
of dennis
yeah i'm just saying i don't know well
that's what he called himself i mean
what
do you think he'd be like [ __ ] puncher
or something like that
tina said she did see the hand last
night instead it was amazing
she watched heavy metal as well but i
need to rewatch it
uh while under the influence of
recreational marriage
hell yeah that's a head movie there
let's see that [ __ ] on acid
i like the opening where the space
shuttle comes and drops
a 50 was a 57 57 corvette out of it and
the dude's in there
yeah that's right i forgot about the
space suit he re-enters the atmosphere
hits the ground bounces and then the
parachute comes out
and then he drives home to get his
little daughter the loch nar and it
[ __ ] melted him when he came out
and then uh jumps all over the place
they even have like a blade runner story
then they have another story where
some guys are on a in a uh in a b17
doing a bombing run
over [ __ ] i guess germany and they
look and there's a foo fighter behind
him and the
all the crew gets killed and the foo
fighter is actually the lochner the
lochnar
and it brings the [ __ ] dead bodies
back becomes a zombie tale that was
[ __ ]
badass yeah somebody said earlier that
that was their favorite segment yeah i
think that was probably my favorite
segment too
well i also like the ones about the
aliens and the big smiley face that
[ __ ] stole the hot [ __ ]
secretary and the alien and the robots
yeah that was the one that that had like
harold raymond
yeah like a whole bunch of like kind of
yeah all the dudes from ghostbusters
yeah
they had all these badass bands from the
70s in the very early 80s you know
ronnie james dio was in it you know from
black sabbath and mob rules and uh just
devo was in it and just all kinds of
you know who else was in that do you
remember think i don't have a ted nugent
and it's just
like you know i feel like if ted was in
their way would have commented on it
had um donald fagan you know the dude
yeah okay you're right dude from stevie
dan he did a song love steely dance i
love you guys
stevie dan's very sentimental music okay
it's it's loser music
you take a loser [ __ ] and then you bring
it to a high art farm
you know it's like gamblers that lose
all their money people that lose all
their [ __ ] in [ __ ] las vegas people
that [ __ ]
you know just nothing but down on their
luck but then you kind of turn it into a
romantic theme you know what i mean
that's that's that's
stevie davis like that yeah that's how
you got to make yourself feel better
because you're like you know yeah you
lost your [ __ ] and you're like
the saxophone i i play just like i feel
i drink scotch whiskey all night long
and die behind the wheel
but it's okay yeah it's good yeah
i forgot how they go they got a name for
the winners in the world
i i want a name when i lose they call
alabama the crimson tide
call me deacon blues deacon blues
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah see
he loves that
i love that [ __ ]
all right so uh yeah so we had a couple
of shout outs and then we also have
a funny pookie story that we should
probably tell before we get too much
into
into the witchery um so yeah so
some of the shout outs we have okay so
we have a new patron this week ian
from the uk so hello and thank you very
much welcome to
patreon yeah uh also i want to give a
shout out to karen who is one of our
patrons from before and
drastically increased her support so
thank you very much
karen also as many of you have noticed
we have broken
10 000 subscribers on youtube
go us i didn't think it would happen
i mean i knew it would happen eventually
but it just seemed like it took a really
long time
i think we got 10 well when i looked
this morning i think it was 1016 or
something like that
so i think they're artificially
suppressing this a lot of people are
saying that they've changed the
algorithms just for everybody across the
board
that if you don't have any corporate
ties
to their to them and and if you don't
have any corporate ties to anybody there
isn't any kind of deal between the
corporation and youtube you're going to
be suppressed
i believe that well i think what they
did was they changed the algorithms to
reward more audience engagement yeah um
so people need to like so
videos that have more likes or more
comments or even more dislikes
as long as people are like interacting
with it then it
seems to push it farther up in the
algorithm so that's what i heard anyway
i'm not really sure about that
yeah that's right there um ricky don't
lose that number was in there journey
steve his journey and stevie nicks was
also
yeah i'm really stevie yeah the heavy
metal was a [ __ ] good movie i forgot
who sent it to me man but thanks for
sending that movie to me
i i had only seen little bits of it as a
kid and
looking back on it i probably saw maybe
like an edited version of it because
there's a lot of [ __ ] sex and nudity
animated sex and nudity in it so it was
probably pretty heavily edited it was
super smart
it was good though real good i liked it
very 70s 70s early 80s
it was back when they didn't give a [ __ ]
they just told you the goddamn story
they didn't care if it was inappropriate
or not
they didn't give a [ __ ] if it was male
gaze oriented
you know that one about that blade
runner story was mostly about that
girl's [ __ ]
cleavage and [ __ ] her legs remember
yeah the girl was trying to steal the
lognar the [ __ ]
yeah that one that was pretty cool i
just liked it
yeah just liked it yeah heavy metal 2000
i feel like i was just
i just saw that on i mean i didn't see
the movie but i saw it
on toby or something like that
tina says she loves stephen dan and then
she goes sing tom and kevin
i gotta sing sometimes i'm just i'm not
really warmed up yeah he's like not even
drunk
i'm not even drunk i'm not my voice
isn't warmed up oracle just snuck in i
saw that
yeah you can't sneak we saw you
that's uh that's okay don't be
self-conscious yeah um but yeah so
let's see what are some of the other
shout outs oh
so as i said earlier i'm i'm i've been
undergoing this very long and tedious
process
of taking uh novels that i wrote and
doing new
print editions of them doing new ebook
editions of them and doing audiobook
editions
now my novel the five poisons i first
published
it in print in 2014
but i've done a new version of it the
print version ebook version's got a new
cover like i've corrected all the
mistakes that were in there
um i thought there were none but i guess
i was wrong um i've also done an
audiobook version
but and it's all uploaded but it's still
going through like the [ __ ]
whatever they do you know it takes like
a couple of weeks while they have to
like do all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
so uh when that's up i'll announce it
but the print and ebook versions are up
also um oh so yesterday
yeah yeah last night what you talking
about last night with pokey yeah
yeah we have a pookie story um
[Laughter]
man i woke up last night it was like it
was 2 30 in the morning right i woke up
last night and i hear those
cookies claws just tearing up the damn
carpets a certain sound
and usually that's associated with her
playing with that damn hair rubber band
she loves these like little rubber bands
the rubber hair she loves those things
she'll pull them and throw them
but it's all happening in one spot that
way i wake up and what the [ __ ] i had my
headphones on
and i'm looking and i see her
jumping up and down and smacking the
ground next to this damn
black dot it's kind of dark i can only
see through the moonlight then the black
dot moves
then she jumping up and down next to it
but not talking not touching it
and i go man that's a [ __ ] palmetto
bug that's a cockroach
yeah so i had a tactical light next to
the [ __ ] bed and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] i hit hit it with the light
and there's a big old [ __ ] palmetto
bug about an inch and a half long they
come underneath the damn
door and she's trying to warn me she's
daddy get it get it she's so funny
because it's like she wants to contain
it but she thinks
they're gross she doesn't she doesn't
want to touch them she doesn't want to
touch she won't touch him but she'll
jump right which i don't blame her i
don't want to touch it
tear up the carpet right next to it and
run a circle around it
get it she can't get it but she won't
touch it
she won't touch it she's gonna get it
get it she just tries to she's like i
would get it but they're so yucky
yeah so she's trying to keep it from
escaping yeah she's like dancing
like jumping around stay here stay here
stay here like until daddy gets up yeah
[ __ ] hilarious so i got up i killed
it [ __ ] threw it and
threw it in the toilet flushed it and
then like just started being living in
dagobah man florida is just
satan's ass crack it really is and
you're just trying to keep
the swamp out out of the damn house
sometimes
unsuccessfully yeah and yeah but pookie
is on guard
yeah after we threw the roach away like
after you flushed her oh she was sitting
she went
right back to the window and she was
like looking out like she was not the
winner was the sliding glasses
she knows that's where they come out
she's like guarding it she's like i got
this
yeah i got this that's how they get in
but she did like jump up on the bed
afterward like for her little reporter
it cracks me up the way she won't touch
them no she won't touch it
although the weird thing i don't know if
it's her or if it's beijing because
every now and then i'll get up and find
like
cockroach pieces yes beijing beijing
i'll eat them she'll tear them a piece
tear them into pieces and eat them yeah
see i don't think pookie will because
she thinks they're disgusting
so but she likes they they make her very
upset but she's like she doesn't want to
she's like getting close to him like
yeah
somebody get it no beige bass beats them
to death
and then tears them apart and then
slowly gets mad at them and eats them
after they're dead
she's [ __ ] crazy and then she leaves
like yeah and wings and [ __ ]
because i've walked out and seen pieces
of roach
run up to the pieces and look at me like
i got it and then eat a piece
and then walk off like [ __ ] it's nasty
it's nasty
they're very dirty yeah i feel like
beijing is too old to give a [ __ ] she's
kind of like whatever
if she chase it and kill it she eats it
i'm gonna call her out there [ __ ]
eating
eating a damn um a gopher and a uh
squirrel yeah i bet she had half a
squirrel out there she's pulling
pulling his guts out yeah it was
something yeah
she's and i love and i love that yeah
she's a psychopath she's nuts yeah but i
love
that beijing did that but then pookie
tried to take credit for it
yeah yeah yeah yeah like beijing did it
because
i killed it so you didn't kill she's
like don't look and she kind of threw it
she's like look i got it
and we're like we know you didn't do
that beijing did that earlier yeah she
was a kitten when she did that
she was trying to impress us i guess all
right that's enough of a poop story
yeah but yeah it was very very funny
she's protecting us from the cockroaches
so you know we appreciate it also i want
to say yesterday um
i actually had a really nice day
yesterday because um
i masked up and went down to downtown
sanford which is only about eight or
nine miles from here
and it's kind of like a cool little it's
very small it's like only a few blocks
that's where mannequins is
which we've mentioned before like the
nightclub that our friend owns
but it's kind of like a little artsy
kind of there's tons of like little
cafes and little like
antique shops and [ __ ] like that so what
um roy uh
mahandran said he put purchase the
unseen hand on audible
nice uh he needs to do a review on it my
bad he says great book
thank you very much uh michael uh
schaefer asked me he said
tom you and i are the same age you ever
watched star blazers yeah what i
remember star blazes
uh there was another one too remember uh
um you had star blazers and then was it
what was everyone called star
force or something where they had the
damn the bad guy was
just a japanese ripoff of batman and
they had uh
like uh four or five teenagers and they
had these [ __ ] capes they'd fly
through space it was kind of like
starblaze and one of them was a [ __ ]
dumb little kid who had a damn helmet
with a
look like a clear duck bill off the top
floor burgle said oracle said galaxy
rangers
galaxy rangers was that it i don't think
so maybe maybe it was galaxy range
it was kind of like not as good as star
blazers but i remembered it i got to
look back into my [ __ ] roll of decks
and see what that was
they roll it in yeah i just remembered
it now your mental rolodex yeah
the bad guy was basically just a ripoff
of [ __ ] batman he just had a longer
pointier nose
well you gotta skirt that copyright
somehow yeah um
oh my god ken just told a really gross
story so there's a buddy in texas had a
party and we were trashed like you do
and a big palmetto bug walked up the
wall across the ceiling
and fell off right into the dip just
like a platform
oh one time a long time ago i was at my
grandmother's house
and i had a shirt hanging in the closet
that had like a pocket you know like a
breast pocket and i put it on and that
rich came climbing out of the breast
pocket when i put the shirt on
yeah i'm still screaming to this day
taylor's talking about florida and the
high humidity it's all the high heat
yeah it's
without air conditioning you just could
not live here the houses would just mold
and rot away
yeah like i said it's just like constant
small baths yeah everything has swamp
bass
not not just your ass some of these old
houses that were built in the 50s they
weren't really made for central air
and i don't understand we got friends
that live in them and they just
man they just they're just never right
you walk in there and
just they feel very dank and they just
never really smell right and they just
if they need to tear them [ __ ] things
down but people owe them own them
you know they're not any any cheaper
than the newer houses that's the thing
you know what i mean like this house
here this is a newer house about 11
it doesn't cost you any more to live
here than it does one of those old 50s
houses
no well depending on depending on the
area depends on the area but
it's about the same i think you know
but uh no without air conditioning i
don't know how people lived here back in
the old days
well they didn't live here back in the
old days i mean
people did but it was very sparsely
popular yeah it's not like nowadays yeah
i mean you know it did this didn't
really start getting super popular at
least central florida like until
maybe yeah yeah geforce it was called
g-force that was the name of that damn
cartoon that's right g-force
man i forgot about that i haven't heard
that in a long time
i vaguely remember that i don't think i
ever watched that
but yeah so uh as i was saying uh i
actually went down to
uh downtown sanford yesterday with a
couple friends of mine
and we had a really good time just kind
of like wandered around the city poking
around in some of the shops like i said
and uh in one of the shops which was
like a bookstore
like a used bookstore called uh i think
it's called maya's
and it's just really big it's like one
floor is books and then the second floor
is all
records and i got not only did i get
this kick-ass
bride of frankenstein shirt you guys
yeah
well if you took the little banner away
you could see it hold on i have to go
we could actually run without the banner
for a while
it looks good yeah see yeah i got this
yeah you guys can see them big old jugs
look at the size everybody you want to
leave the jugs on
there man proudly display
all the guys are going to be in the
comments thanking me
oh look somebody says tom turn her
sideways okay
turn her sideways oh and now and now my
thing is okay
sorry the laptop is in the way too i
didn't realize um
but also yeah so i got this in the
bookstore they also had like they had a
bunch of like horror movie t-shirts i
was really excited
also they had i didn't buy it because it
was 125
and also it was like too big for me to
carry around for the rest of the day but
they had a massive
print from of all things the movie dead
and buried
yeah which man i was like so random
that movie scared me when i was like oh
my god i love that movie and i was like
that's so weird that that's
that happened to be like the one big
movie poster that they had
and i was just kind of like man i kind
of want that i think i saw that movie
just maybe
months before a math mountain thing went
down that movie scared me back then
it's kind of a creepy movie yeah we did
we did a retrospective on it
yeah and i was seeing it at a time where
i didn't know much about the zombie
uh um you know myth what do you call it
zombie uh
[ __ ] not with those um what the
[ __ ] word am i thinking of
getting [ __ ] getting tired i don't
know um the genre i didn't really know
much about
zombie genre you know what i mean i
didn't see um
i saw knight living dead but i didn't
see dawn of the dead i didn't know there
was a zombie
genre really back in the early 80s late
70s
so i didn't know really where that fit
it was just a weird [ __ ] movie
you know what i mean it is really weird
yeah that's why i was like sit well i
was so weirded out like when i walked up
and i was like oh random i was like
that's so strange
they said they're bringing people back
to life they're killing people i didn't
really they didn't really have any other
movie posters just that one it had like
a really really nice
like frame on it like a like an oil
painting type of frame and it was
big and it was 125 and i was just kind
of like man if that was 125 dollars it
probably didn't weigh like 40 pounds
so i could like lug it around on my back
all day but what i did do
stupidly because i think the bookstore
was the first place that we went into
because i was like
but you know me and like you know my two
girlfriends were just like whoa
bookstore yay that's like used books i'm
like cheap book i'm all about it
so we were in there for like forever and
stupidly i was like like i need more
books but you know i justified it as a
business expense because i do the book
review show now
and even though i still have a huge pile
of books to get through i could always
use more so
i got i had a little bit of a book haul
got
got a peter stroud novel that i hadn't
read got a dan
simmons book that i hadn't read that i'm
very very excited about i was i
that was the first one i picked it up
and like i read the thing and i was like
oh yes please i'm having this
and i got a richard lehman paperback got
a frank peretti
so those will be on the show eventually
but i was very very excited but then at
the antique store i had to buy
a cheap backpack to carry because
stupidly i did not bring a backpack with
me
so i had to bring it but i had to buy a
backpack
and put the books in so we could walk
around for the rest of the day but yeah
it was like really fun downtown
stanford's pretty cool
i we've been down there a couple times
like i said to go to mannequins but it
wasn't ever
anywhere i really like explored but
there's all kind of like cool [ __ ] down
there like all these little antique
shops all these like little weird
we went to this one place called triple
goddess that was kind of like
i thought it was more going to be like
more a wiccan store but it was actually
kind of more like a weird
boutique that had like all this weird
like gothy jewelry and like weird
they had these really cool like they
looked like those um
those weird like candles like catholic
candles except they had like all the
universal monsters on them
those were kick-ass i was actually gonna
buy those but then i was like well i
don't want to carry breakable things
around for the rest of the day so i
didn't get them
and i had already spent like so much
money on shirts and books and
pushing almost 50 people and coffee you
know almost 50 people
in the in the uh watching the stream so
that's good
oracle says speaking of books the hollow
places by t kingfisher might be up your
alley you know what
you are the second person that has
recommended that to me so i'm actually
going to write that down right now
because
i have a couple books that i want to buy
and that might be on my next
purchasing thing kayla's talking about
her and her husband moving to
i think he said new mexico new mexico
what are you looking at see what you're
talking about dj maniac said i heard
richard layman
i guess i have uh some of his books but
i they had one there that i hadn't read
so i got that yeah
arizona would be great i love the desert
i've loved the desert since i was a kid
it's nice and dry
uh you can do a lot of stuff a lot of
dirt biking and stuff a lot of adventure
and at night it's nice and cool
sometimes cold i've always liked the
desert
and i think i started going my dad
started taking me when i was like
[ __ ] seven or eight out of the mojave
thank you tim thanks tim and then uh
it ended up in the damn sinai desert in
egypt man [ __ ] the egyptian deserts
were [ __ ] like
it was like mars man i got pictures of
it i need to show those one of these
days
me out there [ __ ] camels and [ __ ]
bedouin bedawina
me and the bedouin kids hanging out we
were doing uh vehicle patrols out
out in the sinai i had to do with a wax
planes and stuff it's kind of a long
story
but uh no i [ __ ] love the desert or
just something about it
it's really i've never been i've never
been to arizona but i have been in new
mexico
i went to uh santa fe like a couple
years back and it was like really really
cool because i'm
to somebody that grew up in you know
swamp ass land
like i did um seeing
some place that looks like santa fe new
mexico it's just like an alien planet
you know what i mean but in a good way
like it was super cool sinai is even
more alien the egyptian desert
is [ __ ] bizarre it's like mars
and i tell you what man it's manly the
desert is a manly [ __ ] place
it's a high testosterone that's his main
like criteria
for like pretty much everything we were
living out in it oh somebody just gave
me another book recommendation right
down to harvest like i said i'm gonna
buy like i just bought four but
i'm always on the lookout for new [ __ ]
so if anybody has like any good scary
like scare the [ __ ] out of me come on
or it could be super [ __ ] up too i
love that i love that [ __ ] used to sleep
out in the desert man we'd see those
[ __ ] egyptian cobras
those wouldn't those wouldn't scare me i
ran down an egyptian cover one time and
tried to catch him
but i gave up yeah i gave up i was like
you know what if i did get a bit
i [ __ ] wouldn't make it in time you
know anyway
yeah that was just a lot the thing that
really bothered me though
in egypt is that we had these things
called camel spiders
oh yeah they were [ __ ] i've seen
those i mean i've seen pictures of them
there yeah this yellow looking down
spider with a couple of beaks on it
and they'd walk up on you while you were
asleep and they would
numb a part of your skin and start
gnawing and they would ch
eat a big hole in you i never got to eat
too i never got eaten but a friend of
mine named phil cobb got eaten it ate it
ate a hole in him
about the size of a silver dollar maybe
about an eighth of an inch deep
oh man it looked [ __ ] bad good thing
it wasn't on his face though
because it healed up yeah that would
suck [ __ ] man
the only way the only spider story i
have is that when my brother was a
little bit younger
probably he was probably a teenager in
his twenties he got bitten by a brown
recluse
the country's knee and he got blood
poisoning the camel spider wasn't a
spider though
that's just what they called it the
camel spider was more like a scorpion
yeah yeah i don't even think it had it
didn't have eight legs i think it had
ten well then it's not a spider or a
scorpion
well it didn't have claws like a
scorpion instead i think it had another
pair of legs up there
like peta pops yeah okay you know that's
what it had
so maybe it is a spider then no i think
it was a [ __ ] it was a scorpion
okay uh it didn't have it didn't have a
tail that curled up on it
but it was a flat [ __ ] like a flat
scorpion tail almost kind of like
the ass on a tick or something or
tickets
like a tick ass or something or you know
you know a cockroach's ass
i try not to look too hard adam but yeah
i know like a flat
yeah it was like that or you know what
it looked like remember those kind of
like remember those
uh potato bugs yeah it looked like a
potato bug with real long legs on it
that's what it looked like it was ugly
yeah okay real ugly and
beaks alex souza said bear girls ate one
of course he did with a side of zone p
i don't know what he's talking about oh
bear grylls
you don't know who bear grylls is he was
like the [ __ ]
he did that show he's like that british
like special forces guy
and he'd show you how to do like
survivalist [ __ ] what do you eat a camel
spider
he ate everything he ate snakes he ate
he drank his own pay he did all this
other kind of stuff which probably he
didn't have to do but whatever he's just
kind of trying to show you
hey if you're attracted they would drop
him in different environments like on
the show
it was the same thing as man versus was
it man versus wild there was there was
more than one like going around
i like bear grylls cause he was british
but i i heard
i don't know if this is true but i heard
that as soon as the cameras went off
they just like picked him up i just hit
my elbow on the table they just picked
him up in a van and like he went and
stayed at the hilton
which i don't know if that's true enough
you're talking about carl's bad camera
my mom took me to carlsbad cameron i was
like about
eight that [ __ ] scared me but it was
cold down in that [ __ ] cave
and you could walk down in there there
was one probably turn the lights off and
it was just [ __ ]
pitch black in there i'm kind of into
caves though in a weird way
yeah and yes i've seen the descent
carlsbad caverns [ __ ]
it was a trip i went in some like i went
in some cool caves when i was in wales
and i was just kind of like man
i could live in here i like it yeah just
like
you know what i mean just like when i
used to see people that like made houses
like out of
like in underground like they were
little underground caves they made a
house out of them like i could i could
live in that
i don't need a window or like see sun or
nothing [ __ ] that
i'm a dark i'm like gollum you know what
i mean
it's all right is it about time to start
the show you think probably now that
we're like [ __ ] 42 minutes in and
probably people are still complaining
about witches well we're trying to make
like we're trying to make like a
three-hour show
well you know and we're just kind of
here like talking to you yeah
we're just telling you guys what are
what our days have been like
lately well we always [ __ ] warm up
for about 40 minutes
yeah we got to get a little bit gotta
warm up you know
liquored up before we really get too
much i was saying already
you did i even said which i have to sing
again if you sang
this early yeah i don't know what you're
going to be doing at the end you might
be naked by the end of the day
they'll pull they'll pull our
monetization well you already
showed like naked titties but they
weren't real titties they were drawing
no they're illustrations
they're illustrations yeah hopefully
nobody likes
don't trip no well all our [ __ ] gets
limited anyway just because we're always
talking about murderers no when i was
doing research on that and they actually
showed the inside of all those comic
books in whole videos so
and like that artist actually sells big
prints and stuff
and it's it's all nudes it's barbarian
nudes and [ __ ] just like right out of
the comic book
i don't have a i just like i don't know
why people would have a problem with
nudity
[ __ ] they're called breasts as rick
from the young lady it started off you
know i mean it was [ __ ]
[ __ ] real religious people and now
it's all these [ __ ]
you know new church people you know
that's not proper oh that's [ __ ] male
gaze [ __ ] i don't want to hear that [ __ ]
come on i'm a product of the 70s and the
80s well the thing is it's just like
it's a body it's a body you know what i
mean
i can i can see if you want to censor
like photos of like murdered
people and [ __ ] like that okay it's
straight up porn or porn yeah sure
it's like i can see that i mean you
don't like you know but you can tell
people hey we're gonna show pictures
like cause sometimes i've seen like some
true crime documentaries that say hey
we're going to like show crime scene
photos if that's going to upset you then
don't watch it or skip over it
and they were a whole right erotic nude
sculptures and art
were [ __ ] publicly there was that was
acceptable even in the victorian era and
those people were [ __ ] uptight
yeah yeah they were uptight in some ways
the lamps would be just naked women
with all the nymphs yeah you know what i
mean even [ __ ] early car hoods in the
1920s is just some naked chick flying
through the air that's what's on the
[ __ ] front of the map
that's what's on the front that's the
hood ornament of the car there's a
[ __ ] naked chick flying through the
air
i don't understand it people are uptight
michael shafer said if i had breasts i
would never have gotten married
it's oh man
i used to laugh because they do make
it's funny because you know everybody
knows they make sex
like sex dolls like you know real dolls
and stuff but the funniest thing to me
is that they also make
like partial like so you can just buy
like say
an ass or a pair of breasts yeah
you know what i mean yeah which that's
very funny to me it's like if you don't
want to deal with the whole woman
here just have like a vinyl pair of
breasts that you can stick your like
my chest is bigger than the average
woman's i'm not [ __ ] married
[Laughter]
i put most of you [ __ ] to shame
i'll meet teddy too oh meat meat titty
yeah
oh sanderson farms
carve it up yeah look like get the [ __ ]
off me
like that [ __ ] straight up [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] up
it's all that straight up [ __ ] turkey
meat it's like this
turkey meat yeah give me some breast
hey we got a turkey i'm gonna get a
turkey [ __ ] probably tomorrow the
next day you know what
yeah we haven't got a shark yet guys i
gotta start thawing that [ __ ] in that
back refrigerator to be ready in time
well [ __ ] if you buy it if you just buy
it tomorrow you don't have to freeze and
then i'll buy another one the day after
when all the [ __ ] prices fall
yeah and then we can have that for
christmas leftover [ __ ] turkey
yeah we'll make two turkeys because
honestly like i like trick you people
need to know this some of everybody
is that everybody knows that [ __ ] you
get to turkey for christmas or for
thanksgiving
when the day after it's over go down
there and go get you the leftover
turkeys they'll have that [ __ ] 50
off because man i never get sick of like
thanksgiving food i love that
no i'll make a turkey again i love that
[ __ ] well i think we didn't we do that
last year last year hell yeah
because we had we had two turkeys i
think and then like we so we made one
for thanksgiving and then we made
another one for christmas
turkey fest 2019. it was and i was there
for it and it was weird is that the cats
won't eat turkey
give the cat a piece of turkey like nah
that doesn't have great which is weird
yeah because like the
one of their favorite well pookie's
favorite flavor of cat food is turkey
and cheese
yeah it's it's all slightly above like
the fishy flavors she looks like stinky
fish flavors i'll take that but turkey
and cheese is her favorite i have the
stuff in the dressing i make the [ __ ]
two different kinds of gravy i'll make
the damn gravy out of the damn stock for
the [ __ ]
brazilian cream corn you make brazilian
cream corn
i'll have like the stuff that came out
of the stock pot
when i'm done with that make the because
you got some of that ends up going into
my
in into my into my stuff and some of
that ends up being gravy after i'm done
with that and i'll puree
all those vegetables down the vegetables
and the [ __ ]
like the uh uh the the the turkey stock
and turn that into i got two different
gravies i'll do one that would be like
giblet gravy and the other one's kind of
like a vegetable gravy
turkey vegetable gravy yeah in case i
think i made it three different ones
last time didn't i
you might have yeah yeah and they were
all good they were all good
because i don't like that damn liver
i don't like that liver in there it's
too i don't hate it but it's not
it's a little iron but i do like the
gizzard and the heart
and i like that yeah yeah
you're full of turkey yeah yeah that's
your priority
[Laughter]
but uh yeah we'll do that again but i'll
take that whole [ __ ] turkey carcass
and have that [ __ ] rendered down just
all the bones out of it nothing but just
meat maybe like a couple drumsticks and
i'll have that in a damn tupperware
container i'll break it down real quick
we we went through it pretty fast well
because i love
turkey's turkey sandwiches i mean you
get some really good like
dense bread yeah you put turkey you put
stuffing you put cranberry sauce you put
[ __ ]
mashed potatoes on it why not get the
frozen dough and let that rise a little
bit of mayo
and then make all make all those dinner
rolls and i make the
yeah and then turkey sandwich on the
dinner roll homemade cranberry sauce
yeah we don't do that [ __ ] with the can
when it's like
no work get those frozen cranberries and
then put some down
pecans in it and mash it all up sugar
cook it
and make your own make your own it's so
much better well cranberry sauce is
pretty easy to make i like nut i like
pecans in it yeah i'm not like a huge
fan of cranberry sauce but if you're
going to make like a turkey sandwich it
needs cranberries
on it with gravy and stuffing yeah well
the sandwich needs all this [ __ ] it
needs all that chicken it needs all the
sugar it's got the sandwich
must be 2 500 calories per serving
i'm sure it's probably more than that
actually depending on the size itself
thank you
i think you're you're going more to like
five thousand calories
it's like [ __ ] put a slice of pumpkin
pie on there too why not ask me what my
cup size is my cup size
you want to borrow one of my smaller
bras and see if that probably
let's see i'm gonna let me squeeze the
let me see
it's not it's probably about a b no i
probably about to see
oh is that b i don't know no grab it
grab the meat you could have the whole
time
yeah but here do you even know how to
measure for no i don't know he doesn't
know i'm measuring for bra
they're just grabbing [ __ ] and go
yeah that's about a b right there that's
mine well see that's not that's
shows what you know what the bra sizes
for dudes that don't know
yes i don't have any sag this just
looking up high as rock
rock hard you know what i mean like yeah
well that's why i'm thinking like no
i don't know i don't mean like any
insult or anything
yeah but the cup size yeah i mean the
number that's at the front like 36 38
that's how
that's how many inches you are around
right here
but the cup size is how many inches is
between
under your boob and pointy boot and
where your nipple is all right
so it's like if you don't so like one
inch is a cup
two inches is b cup three inches of c
cup and so on and so forth
so i feel like you don't have because
they're not jutting out
you know what i'm saying okay i'm not
you know they don't matter i don't care
so i'm just saying i don't you know if
you if you were anything you would have
to it would be an a cup maybe i'm mostly
bullshitting i'm just trying to put the
show on you're talking about
they're asking what my [ __ ] titty
size is i brought i'm one that brought
it up
so i was asking for it then they want to
know exactly what cup size is
and they can have these [ __ ] girls
that's what i'm saying the girls asking
this [ __ ] you know i mean they want to
see you do the whole measurement have to
make a whole measurement video
yeah i'm gonna yeah we're gonna have to
get like the best
measuring tape in here
[Laughter]
because she knew how funny it would be
yeah by my
bras i usually get like 36 d or 36
double d
depending on the bra because some of
them like you can't ever get one
that fits the same as the other one
because sizes are [ __ ]
so as every woman knows because i have
things of all different sizes and they
all fit differently because there's no
standardization
yeah and what's funny is you go to japan
and all the [ __ ] sizes are claimed to
be much
like two sizes bigger than they actually
are did you know that
yeah that's why when i order clothes
from asia i always order like three
sizes larger than i would normally get
i heard some japanese girls [ __ ]
talking about it on one of these videos
on youtube it had all the subtitles
and they had some japanese girl
explaining to the other japanese girls
she's
she's like yeah i'm on a big big i'm
like a c cup and he goes yeah but not in
america
and what are you talking about the cup
sizes are totally different in america
you'd be about a b
cup or an a well yeah that's what i mean
the sign saying they were like really
and they were like yeah
they were like they expand all that [ __ ]
out here in japan to make you feel
better that's what the japanese girls
well i feel like that's probably what
they did in the us too but like in the
opposite direction
you know what i mean so they're kind of
saying that's like oh it's a size six
but actually in another country it'd be
like a size 18 or some [ __ ]
you know that's not that's an
exaggeration but i'm just saying that's
kind of what they do over here
but the weird thing about it is that
men's clothing sizes
are standard i mean you go you're a man
you go get a pair of pants
it's like waist inseam it's in inches
they don't do that with women's clothes
like oh you know if i get a dress
that's a size like six or eight or
something like that in one brand
and if i get a six size six or eight in
another brand it'll be too big or too
small or something like
it's there's no standardization girls in
the comments talking about bras now and
all the men down there saying that
they're getting wood
wow that's all we have to do yeah yeah
that was easy
it's [ __ ] fun [ __ ] bras man i
think i got into that discussion on one
of the last shows we got into like the
bra discussion because all the
every woman that has ever had to buy a
bra yeah
is you have everybody has one bra that
fits exactly right and when that
bra breaks like you cry because you're
like well [ __ ] now it's like i don't
because they're expensive yeah yeah
they're all talking about
or i have one brush that fits right
they're on there talking about the asian
sizes and everything those asian sizes
are all
[ __ ] they're all [ __ ] [ __ ]
well yeah if it was here
if i was getting pants or a skirt i
would get a medium or a large yeah
over there i have to get like xxl and
sometimes that's
yeah and because i have like big thighs
yeah
it's funny it was funny hearing these
japanese girls explaining one japanese
girl explained to the other japanese
girls
it was on asian boss i think all right
there's
a channel on there and somebody was
talking to the japanese girls about cup
size and this and that and then the
person who is actually doing the
interview
was like telling them that the sizes in
the west are different
yeah that they're that that you know
that because you might be a c
in japan you're not a c in america so
you know and they were saying they've
adjusted that for
what they say for psychological reasons
well yeah because nobody wants to feel
like
boob greed oh and flat
because here's the shitty thing greed is
universal across the earth the shitty
thing though
is that i feel like you know speaking of
being universal
i feel like the world over women
everywhere
no matter what they have if they have
big boobs or small boobs or whatever
it's like
everybody is always dissatisfied with
what they have it's like i wish i had
something else
like oh i have straight hair i wish i
had curly hair curly hair girls wish
they had straight hair like
big boob girls wish they had smaller
boobs like smaller boob girls which they
have bigger boobs it's like no one's
like happy
yeah they were showing houses they were
showing they were showing them pictures
of like actresses that they knew
you know i mean like uh you know they
had implants
you know like uh you know that any uh
what was the one
who's that [ __ ] crazy ass skinny one
the crazy ass
crazy you're gonna have to narrow it
down angelina [ __ ] jelly
yeah this is back when she was you know
rocking a
decent set like back in tomb raider time
she got breast cancer though didn't you
yeah yeah
and and they were like
some girl was like saying yeah i'm a c
cop she goes oh because you should
then you should be about the same as
angelina jolie they show her pictures of
that from that movie
yeah yeah about that side and he was
like no no and then they talk about the
differences
in the sizings is over here that would
be like a [ __ ]
an f an f cup and they're oh so it's
different
yeah it's very different the proportions
were very
the proportions have been tweaked for
psychological reasons for marketing
reasons in japan well yeah like i said
if you're a smaller framed
yeah um you know you're going to be like
over here you're going to be an a-cop
yeah yeah that's just what and then
you can be small framed look at look at
look at that well
that depends on genetics
one two and that also depends on surgery
because
[ __ ] our friend [ __ ] uh sonia that
we haven't seen in years
all right she was very small frame she
was what maybe five feet tall and
about 90 pounds maybe 90 pounds and she
was
what that was flicking 650cc
implants yeah that wasn't natural triple
d
maybe i'm saying naturally i'm just
saying obviously
nature's got nothing to do with this if
you have implants this is boobs
obviously if you have implants that's a
different issue i'm just saying if
you're naturally small you can see them
boobs from the back
you could yeah yeah well she was very
very small right yeah i mean not just
yeah thin she was like also very short
yeah you know what i mean she's just a
tiny tiny woman
but yeah she had very big implants well
the implants weren't they were big but
they they looked big on her they just
looked big on her because she was like
so small
yeah yeah you know everywhere else right
so whereas you know somebody who was
like larger framed and they got the same
thing it wouldn't look as i mean
everybody we know is some kind of freak
anyway
they're not normal proportioned well
yeah
either they're especially when they were
younger
you know what i mean we've been hanging
out for over 10 years now some of them
really
they've changed a lot faster we hang out
with a bunch of weirdos
[Laughter]
some of them like those two cam girls
they're [ __ ] rocking
beach balls i need to find those
pictures
yeah that was from that was probably
three or four years ago
i want to say yeah at escape that fetish
club
yeah and uh yeah you took a bunch of
pictures of yeah i got pictures of
of me and them yeah i haven't seen them
in a long time no they yeah they don't
come out anymore
yeah i mean we don't go out anymore
either obviously because of all this
[ __ ] but
yeah we haven't seen them and i don't
think it's going a couple of years i
think it's going to get even worse
well i guess you know i think it's
apocalyptic don't be debbie downer okay
i think you're going to ratchet it down
and ratchet it down they're gonna stay
in your [ __ ]
pod [ __ ] that's what they're gonna say
and then they're gonna destroy the
entire economy where there's nothing to
do outside
it doesn't mean like north korea that's
what they do there there's no i mean you
stay at home in north korea and then you
you stay at home in north korea if
you're not working because there's
nothing to do
it's a totally minimized economy which
i'm telling but i'm telling you though i
went to downtown sanford yesterday like
i said
safely it wasn't like super crowded
cause it was the middle of the day but
most of the [ __ ] there was open and
like people were doing like normal [ __ ]
that's because florida everybody had
masks on
that's because florida isn't locked down
other states are locked down
or they're trying to yeah but i'm just
saying the thing about it though is that
we had spanish flu back in 1918 1919
it's like it was the same kind of thing
it went cycles there were lockdowns it
was fine there were no
there was another lockdown it was fine
and eventually it took a while but it's
like it
finally was gone and you know i'm just
saying it's i think they lost political
will they just let it run and it burned
out that's what i think happened
well you know like i said just absorb
the casualties
well we already are because just it's
not gonna make any difference
just go to work all right um everybody
has been working yeah like i said
no there's so much people i know but
some people still have to work
okay a lot of people have to work still
um yeah so like i said don't be a debbie
downer
okay i was getting people mentally
[ __ ] prepared
no one needs to get mentally prepared
everyone's mentally prepared everybody
knows what's going on all right
prepare yourself people prepare yourself
prepare your mind people everybody knows
i'm listening to what they're saying in
here
they're talking about titties just
everything they love titties well like i
said you get started you get you go off
on titties and everybody
yeah yeah it was funny that the women
are talking more about the titties than
the man well yeah because we like to
[ __ ] commiserate about that [ __ ]
all right all right it's hard being a
girl guys you could take me later go
ahead and send me some flash bulbs and
some money i i whipped them up into a
frenzy's nothing but just women talking
about boobs
because like i said there's no you know
it's it's really cool to like for your
entertainment
you know what that you know what i think
that was other than
like being able to like go in the used
bookstore and like go be like yay
like look at books forever um and geek
out and stuff i think the nicest thing
about going out with my friends
yesterday was that was the first time
that i had been out just like hanging
out with my girlfriends
like for ages i don't even remember when
the last time that was
yeah so it's like it's nice to like talk
to like girls like in person
michael michael's telling me the girl
too skinny still my sonia i guess he
likes garden gnomes i was laughing the
other day there was a
woman in the comments section that she
was built like a garden gnome
i told her to break it off send us some
features let's see this i'm kind of
built a little bit like a governor
says she was all in that all ass and
everything going on it sounded
titillating but she never sent any
[ __ ] stuff
never sent any [ __ ] pictures i wanted
to see it okay i have to well and like i
said i feel like this is sad because i
feel like
you know i i have never met a woman that
was
happy with her body ever um there's
always something some people are like
pretty much okay but they're like i wish
i could change this
and the other thing and i have the same
thing i have like the weirdest
i was talking to uh to our friend angel
the other day about this [ __ ]
i was like i can't even buy normal pants
because
i'm so short wasted that when i buy
stuff that's supposed to be hip huggers
it comes way up over my belly button
which yeah i don't you know i'm only
five foot three
and like i see like these these women
like in person not just like in
photoshop like fashion magazines or
anything that have like their you know
[ __ ]
torso stretched because they do that but
i've seen women in real life
and i'm like you know they have this
torso and it's like normally
proportioned and like the hip huggers
are like right there i'm like how does
that
like that does not happen when i put
those types of pants on
this because the pants just like come
way up here like right under my titties
because i'm like well because i'm super
short waisted
i have it's like this my torso is like
this long
it doesn't seem to be short waisted
though it is well every that's why i
can't wear into like normal pants that's
why i kind of wear
i have like these yoga pants that are
long and flared and they're thick so you
can wear them for like business pants
and so i have like three or four pairs
of those and then i have a pair
like three pairs of you know kind of
like same thing but like walking pants
but they're like capris
and they're super comfy so i have three
pairs of those and that's pretty much it
like i just wear this your closet is
filled to the [ __ ] brim
that's just what you wear most time when
you're around the house you got so much
well yeah because they're comfortable
yeah like i have some jeans but i feel
like
even if even if they kind of fit it's
like i have muffin top issues or they
get like uncomfortable when i sit
down or something yeah cause they either
go way up in my crotch or they're like
you know too far down or something
there's always something well we had you
haven't been shopping in a while either
too
some of that stuff that's true yeah you
just need to
some of my [ __ ] i got to throw it out
wait no we're look we're all [ __ ]
we're we're off [ __ ] talking
like an hour into this yeah we haven't
been drinking we're not talking about
[ __ ] what we have in the wardrobe
come on let's get the [ __ ] show on
the road you want to start talking about
we're
talking about the witches we're gonna
talk about witches yeah and they're all
talking about their weight and stuff all
right you guys need to get it off there
and then sophie's talking about girl
issues overflowing
corsets and having issues with three cor
overflowing closets
and issues of three quarters of it yeah
yeah that's exactly
yeah it's pretty much because sometimes
you buy clothes and then like they fit
for like two weeks and then like a week
later you lost a couple pounds or you
gained a couple pounds and now it
doesn't fit right anymore it looks all
[ __ ] up and it's like
and then i have some clothes that i
really like and they fit right but then
they start getting holes in them and
then it's like well i can wear this if i
wear this other thing
over it so you can't see through you
know what i mean so it's just like this
big [ __ ] issue
i thought you were seeing overflowing
corsets i love overflowing
corsets yeah he loves them yeah yeah but
uh but she
yeah okay i got jenny has to show
because we don't believe a word she says
about her yoga pants
i got pictures i got pictures of yoga
pants on right now i got pictures to
[ __ ] proof of everything i have
flared yoga pants on right now i used to
have hot pink yoga pants but they
the ass busted out i think that was fun
[Laughter]
it was probably your fault yeah they
were they were old yeah is what i'm
saying
all the ones i have now are black
because they go with everything and like
i said the nice thing is about these
yoga pants is that
they're not like yoga pants like oh you
can see through them but they're like
really really
thick so you can wear them you can get
away with wearing them for like
business [ __ ] you know what i mean
because they kind of look like
slacks sort of but they feel like yoga
pants
all right so let's talk about some
witches
yeah let's bring it to the witch thing
let's bring it to the witch thing now
how are you doing for
okay i'll get it in a bit yeah well why
don't you talk about something for a
second because i kind of have to
okay so now that we and now everybody
can see my yoga pants
yeah while i stand up see go ahead
yoga pants
all right let's see what everybody's
doing give her a few seconds
i'm gonna go ahead and get some of this
uh tequila
oracle's got to leave already
man we got 60 people in the conversation
already that's [ __ ] awesome
that's a it's good every time we do this
show
we get more and more uh people watching
the live streams
which that's awesome
got people watching from germany oh
sophie you liked the big lebowski big
lebowski was [ __ ] good man that was a
really excellent flick i forgot who it
was that sent me that
but uh yeah that was a good flick it was
kind of like napoleon dynamite in a
certain way but it was like a boomer
version
of napoleon dynamite um
kind of like a detective flick where
this old [ __ ]
burned out [ __ ] stoner gets sent
he gets put on basically they force him
into like a private detective role and
he's totally unprepared for the [ __ ]
he's the last guy you want as a private
detective are you talking about the big
lebowski yeah
uh maria sent us five dollars thank you
marie thank you maria
i'm sorry you could always use something
in my ass then but that's right that was
louis that said that
thanks louie i put the first put the
disc in there and that [ __ ] wasn't
playing i was going what the [ __ ] man
there's something wrong with it i'm
almost tearing the xbox up
underneath that dab piece of paper there
was another disc i was
i was actually putting was the 4k yeah
you put the 4k
put the 4k in there by accident it's a
4k
and a blu-ray i forgot i said well it
was 4k you know oh [ __ ]
i don't have a 4k tv yet i'm gonna get
one though but actually no i do have one
4k out in the living room
it's weird because i wasn't sure like i
saw the big lebowski like probably back
when it came out or a year or two later
and i you know i remembered a lot about
it but i didn't know if you would like
it or not
especially after we watched raising
arizona and you didn't like
that one so i was like i was like oh so
maybe he doesn't like the coen brothers
like whole thing
um no i just thought that one was that
movie was too [ __ ] silly for me
see i loved it but i liked it i liked
the big you probably like fargo the big
lebowski kind of had
first of all it's a masterpiece the edit
and the flow of that movie is perfect
shot composition color palette [ __ ]
really good
every second of that movie is [ __ ]
really good to look at it's real good
storytelling
interesting characters and
and really good [ __ ] soundtrack and
score to go along with it it's just you
know
it'd be hard to improve on that movie
when it comes to that particular story
you know what i'm talking about yeah
that's the way you tell that story
so now you have to see fargo okay i
can't believe you didn't see fargo
i didn't see that one no i love fargo
and then like um
his vietnam veteran buddy walter yeah
yeah walter
played by john goodman yeah john goodman
played it that was a [ __ ] good
character freddy's [ __ ] funny
shut the [ __ ] up donnie shut the [ __ ] up
don yeah now
it's rumored that that character may
have been based a little bit on [ __ ]
john milius the guy who directed
conan because now that guy was not a
vietnam veteran but he liked that kind
of [ __ ]
which that would be crazy if that was
true yeah and everything that john
milius you know
john millions was a [ __ ] badass
jewish dude man [ __ ] there weren't
were another
jewish guys like that he would show up
to the [ __ ] studio heads
with a [ __ ] 1911 concealed he had a
ccw
he'd have that [ __ ] concealed on his
[ __ ] person and he'd start talking to
the studio heads and start negotiating
about the [ __ ] the movies and how
much money and what they were going to
pay for and he'd pull that [ __ ] 45
out put it on that [ __ ] desk like
that
it started pushing yeah start
negotiating with the [ __ ] studio
ahead [ __ ] put a gun on a [ __ ] desk
damn now that's like some [ __ ]
out of when i went to when i went to
israel and was [ __ ] drinking and
working with the [ __ ] idf the israeli
defense force
those dudes were like that but i i've
never met any jewish americans that were
like that
only only only israelis are like that
that's the one that was my ex
personal experience but [ __ ] i don't
know i don't love to [ __ ] hang out
with john elias
he's badass man his [ __ ] daughter's
in the state department she's [ __ ]
she does uh um she shows up sometimes on
aj's show as a guest
on info wars and she's a [ __ ] good
guest man
his daughter smart real good looking and
a lot of information on how state
department works and cia and stuff
so um i don't know if you guys never i
forgot what her name i think i don't
even think her last name is amelia's but
well she might be married or she might
have i think she got married married
yeah
but uh no he his daughter his daughter
is [ __ ] badass his daughter
daughter is kind of like a like a uh
like a gina carino
type but a political version of it you
know state department
person man watching the big lebowski
again last night i was like
seeing john chotaro in that i was like
man that made me want to watch [ __ ]
uh
barton fink again yeah hernandez sent
that to me man thanks for sending it to
me hernandez that's a [ __ ] badass
flip you sent us such a good movie yeah
you sent me good movies and that one
you're right man that's a masterpiece
right there
i like it i'm really glad you liked it
because i was like i never know
like movies like that i never know how
he's gonna react to them you know what i
mean
because like i said when sophie was here
we watched raising arizona because me
and sophie love raising arizona
and tom had never seen it and i was like
oh my god you have sea raising arizona
it's so [ __ ] funny
and like he didn't really like it i
liked uh sophie showed me that um
napoleon dynamite though i liked that
movie which i didn't i did not think you
would like that that was a [ __ ] weird
ass [ __ ] movie
hernandez if you liked
big lebowski all right i want you i want
you to watch [ __ ] art of self-defense
if you haven't seen that
all right yeah he can't stop plugging
that movie i [ __ ] love that movie
artist defense and uh and i also like
[ __ ] um
vivarium that same actor and that same
that
what's that actor's name jesse eisenberg
jesse eisenberg
like i said you probably like the social
network as well which is about
uh mark zuckerberg the founder of
facebook yeah jesse eisenberg he's got
real good tastes in projects i got i got
confidence in the projects he likes
he's got good taste in [ __ ] so if he's
in that movie not all of the movies
because i think some of it's corporate
[ __ ] but all the little indie
independent films that he does i like
them
i mean i think vivarium was easily one
of my favorite movies
yeah easily i mean i just really really
liked the whole like
i like the whole aesthetic of it i just
i just thought it was so [ __ ] cool
it was just one of the it just like got
me like right in the right place you
know what i mean
yeah all right so are you ready yeah go
ahead you sure
yeah i know this is not gonna yeah as
soon as i start talking yeah i'll get
sidetracked okay
but that's up there and they're talking
about the movies and nick cage and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] going on about movies that's
right how can you not love raising oh my
god a cow can you not love raising yeah
come on raising arizona is so [ __ ]
funny
i don't know whatever hernandez says
he's noted artists off the fence
artist self defense is another as
another masterpiece
think about count dante in the [ __ ]
and and the kung fu
the old school martial arts that was
going on
the quackery in martial arts this is
it's
it's a [ __ ] weird movie and very true
it's a very true movie and when i'm
watching i was like man they're
this is like they're talking about cal
dante
you know what i mean and kung fu cults
in the united states [ __ ] like that
really existed
and the weird [ __ ] that they would do so
you would like that movie
jenny didn't think i was going to like
it we saw that one in the theater well
like i said there's always
there's a particular type of movie that
i know you're going to like
yeah but when you get into like weird
indie [ __ ] like that
yeah it's hard to tell like what you're
gonna like and what you're not gonna
like the thing of the thing with
artists self-defense the focus of that
the the theme of that movie was about
toxic
masculinity all right the dude that
wrote it it was he was a real soy boy
but he did understand toxic masculinity
he did understand it
and he doesn't really he's not making
fun of it in a way
he's just showing it and there's truth
to what they're saying
a lot of truth to it and
it was weird i was just thinking
yesterday of the scene where he had
the little uh the little wiener dog like
kick to death yeah yeah because it
wasn't like a manly enough dog yeah
he had to have like a german chair toxic
masculinity is
fake masculinity well it's not real
masculine insecurity
but there's you have to project yes
there's important
lessons to be learned in that just like
tila she watched a hand
and she said she loved that movie and i
think taylor maybe understood that the
conan reference and
why conan who was actually healthy
masculinity
but then the hand was about toxic
masculinity did you see it
did you see it tila did you see what i'm
talking about yeah i think she's cause
that guy was
a giant that was a [ __ ] toxic man
prolapsed anus
right three possible i'm gonna recommend
that one also to tila tila man watch art
of self defense
all right it's it's kind of like
napoleon dynamite but it's about kung fu
you'll see and there's kung fu in
napoleon dynamite
there was that was a lot like a lot like
art of self-defense
yeah that's a there's a crossover there
yeah i'm
drawn but see like movies like that like
i said napoleon dynamite any kind of
movie like that like
like weird like indie comedies or you
know just like weird [ __ ] movies like
that
i'm always i never know how you're going
to react because i feel like you're
either going to love it or you're going
to hate it
yeah yeah where i usually i like that
kind of thing usually
not always i wasn't a big fan of some
[ __ ] like um
what was that movie that came out a
while back that was like that everybody
was talking about garden state
you remember that one i think natalie
portman was in it yeah and it's like you
know it was this kind of like oh sweet
like
you know [ __ ] manic pixie dream girl
kind of [ __ ]
i really did not like that movie i
thought it was like to twee and
uh i couldn't get into it but normally
that type of movie
i usually like movies like that with me
it has to be cinema
is it all about you happen it has to be
cinema with with you know like
yeah yeah yeah it has to be cinema you
have to draw me into it
it's got to have the it's got to have
good acting it's got to take me into
this story
and if it's going to be indie you have
to show me truth
i like truth now truth doesn't
necessarily
mean that truth is delivered you to you
in a realistic way it [ __ ] could be zany
and wacky
but the meaning behind it is true i like
that
okay i gotta jam talk about if it
violates my concept of what reality is
and i go that's not true truth is
you know what i mean when i saw art of
self-defense i went yeah that's true
yeah this [ __ ] was crazy but yeah that's
that's exactly what it is that does
exist
you know man do you want me to my
favorite scene in that is when he
finally like
it's funny because he finally kind of
like nuts up and then like he's at work
and then like all the [ __ ] douches
that he works with and he's just like
straight up punches that dude in the
face
yeah and he gets them to all bow to him
basically that dominates that
scene [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] but he gets
dominant he cracks me he starts
dominating
and then and just but he's still a [ __ ]
that's what's [ __ ] funny about it you
know what i mean well yeah he's not
saying much it's not saying much with
the guys that he worked with but there's
truth to that
yeah i just i just love it
talking about it makes me want to see
that movie again
that movie was like very very funny yeah
makes me want to see it again i showed
that [ __ ] to sophie
when she was here and she wasn't really
sure what to make of it
it's a weird movie yeah and then i
explained it to her and she's like oh
okay all right all right
and what's weird is that a dude like
that really existed
his name was count dante yeah and he was
a [ __ ] kung fu master
self-made kung fu master that you saw in
the damn comic books when you were a kid
can i say the death touch the dim lock
depth touch that's where all that
fake martial arts came from looked like
you know
it was named that [ __ ] movie where
they were going to the [ __ ] the
kumite
um bloodsport yeah it's all made up
of course made up man toxic masculinity
everybody wants to believe
yeah that they have this like magical
power that they're just like they're
powerful and they can just like [ __ ]
that's not how that's not how reality
works but
no i was gonna say that like one thing
that i was really um
i don't know why this struck me so much
but we were watching the extras on the
big lebowski
and they had um there's a lot of extras
on there and there was like a
documentary that
was made at the time that it was being
made like i'm making of and they had
like a 10 years later like retrospective
kind of because obviously
when that came out like fargo was like a
big like critical and
you know public success and like i think
it won some oscars or it was nominated
or whatever
and then when big lebowski came out um
it was kind of like everyone was kind of
met but then like it kind of got a cult
following later on
one thing that i love is they talked to
joel and ethan cohen
and i love the the two they're two
brothers and i love that they just kind
of sat there and picked at their
fingernails like the whole time they
were talking like they were super
nervous about like talking
and i really like i really related to
that because i do that too like what i'm
talking like when i get really nervous
and i thought it was really cool that
they were they were like really um
articulate like about what they wanted
to do and they were really
you know what i mean like they've always
been i've always liked like every single
one of their movies yeah tina's talking
about the hand
said the hand was well directed and
acted well that was uh that was um
oliver stone oliver stone was a [ __ ]
genius
um it's about to sell it um
about a a highly insecure man that hated
the idea of self-examination true
another thing is is that the hand
represented a man's
will to possess okay remember he
drew the hand later on with the woman
inside of it and trying to possess
and it was because he had to grab things
because they wouldn't stay on their own
he was repulsive they'd run from him
yeah so you're trying to possess
[ __ ] he couldn't let go the woman wanted
to leave he couldn't let her leave
so the hand grabs more even prior to
that
he wouldn't even let her have her own
life right her own interests he always
like belittled them
right so the whole thing about being
possessive
and controlling and [ __ ] being the
hand
that it's all a sign of weakness did you
see conan
[ __ ] trying to hold women next to him
no
and he could draw a conan like creature
a chronic conan like character
but he couldn't embody that and then
when somebody else came along and tried
to improve it
to make it better he rejected that
because he couldn't work with others
there's a lot of symbolism in there
a lot of symbolism yeah a lot of truth
in it
it's funny because i saw that movie when
i was a kid
and i mean obviously i it scared the
[ __ ] out of me because like i said i
think i mentioned this when we reviewed
it but
you know limbs or heads or [ __ ] like
that getting cut off is like like really
really upsetting for me
so that's something that like really
stuck with me so his hand that scene
where his hand gets cut off
it was always like really upsetting but
it's like it was interesting for me
because
i remembered that being really scary but
i didn't remember
like all the thematic stuff about it so
i'm really glad that we got to see it
later on
and i was like and then it leaves it
ambiguous because
it talks about the will the willpower
that's also in
in in conan talks about the will
was the hand actually out there
killing people no were people dying by
some kind of psychic force like a
poltergeist force was he killing him
that way
we don't know or was it him a psychopath
killing people
we don't know it leaves it ambiguous
in the very end he was tied up the hand
came out and killed that
psychologist did the hand really do it
we don't know
she did release one hand so maybe that's
you're out maybe he was
that's what i'm saying you have
plausible than i am yeah yeah it could
have just been him
because they did do a flashback where
they did kind of like show him
show him doing it doing this [ __ ] but
you don't know
because then yeah they left it ambiguous
which is good
because stone and milius also kind of
believed in
the power of will and psychic force
they're talking about like the dark side
of the force
yeah you know vader could choke you
without [ __ ] touching you
that was one of his i wish i could do
was it that we don't know
i'd get in so much and that was the kind
of movies that influenced me as a kid
and later on
poltergeist [ __ ] happened and to me i i
thought they were teaching me something
that they were telling me of a reality
but i don't think they knew they were
just
thinking of it they were surmising it
goes back into old legends going back to
chinese legends of the chi
and stuff cheap you know well yeah i do
feel like certain ideas are kind of like
universal universal way back across
cultures sure could a woman be so evil
that she could poison everybody and kill
the crops you know just by her will
and because she did these rituals and
they call her a witch we don't know
that's what that's what the old ancients
believed or the medieval people
and so do the people that we're talking
about on this yeah now you need to get
to this
nice segue yes now that we're already
like an hour and 23 minutes
but like i said you know and now that my
dream my first drink is empty
hopefully i can stay more coherent than
i was on the last one i think i did okay
on the last one i got through most of
the case right i just didn't really
remember
like i kind of woke up in the morning
and i was just kind of like wait did i
even end that stream
i didn't even remember like i was like i
was pretty sure i did because i
remember i sort of remembered like
posting it on instagram which i usually
do right like right after we finished
the show
but i was like wait did i i don't
remember i don't remember yeah so if you
like if elsa if you like [ __ ] count
dante
see art of self defense it's about a guy
like that
you'll like it you'll like it i thought
it was hilarious but you know what i
mean
there's also a lot i have a weird sense
there's a lot of [ __ ] knowledge to be
learned from it when you think about it
my first time seeing you live she looks
a lot different wait i look a lot
different
than what then yeah
is that good or bad i don't know if i
should be offended or not should i be
offended
you did it yeah i did but it's like i
don't know i've got past the point now
because sometimes i try not to like
drink so much that i forget what
happened the night before but sometimes
you know [ __ ] happens and sometimes i'll
wake up at like three or four in the
morning and be like
oh damn wait did i did i end it is it
still running like right now because i
don't know
but then i'm just like nah [ __ ] it cause
you know i'm too old to worry about that
kind of [ __ ] now yeah
so you know uh so yeah so
now that you made that segue into which
is kind of well yeah why don't you make
me another drink all right
it's my shit's almost empty and i'll
start talking about witches without you
jumping in about michael caine oh yeah
okay did he [ __ ] her
did you [ __ ] her whatever all right so
uh
yeah so let's talk about the
less famous than the salem witch trials
but still kind of culturally significant
which trial of
miss margaret matson at l uh
among others so this happened in
pennsylvania and was in fact i believe
the only official witch trial to occur
in pennsylvania during this time period
and during any time period now that i'm
mentioning it
so uh this took place in the 17th
century obviously this was like ten
years
nine years before the much more famous
salem
wish trials so it all started
with cows as many things do
i don't know so we're talking about
margaret matson which sometimes is
filled with two
teas sometimes spelled with one tea
because as most people know
um english didn't really have
standardized spelling until much later
on so people just spelled things
whatever [ __ ] way they felt like um
so
i've seen it spelled both ways i put two
t's
but whatever i've seen it spelled both
ways so like i said
so margaret matson she was a swedish
immigrant
now she had a husband named niels
and they had first come to colonial
america
uh in 1654 from sweden
and they had built this really big they
had 100 acres
of like really really nice farmland
and they built a plantation on it uh
right near
ridley creek which is thank you near the
delaware
river uh for this reason she is
sometimes known as the witch of
ridley creek i have seen her refer to
that a couple of times
now this particular farm like i said
they owned 100 acres
um was known what was known as new
sweden
um this area had been settled by mostly
swedes obviously
in starting in 1637
um this area is what would now be like
uh northern part of northern delaware
like all the way up to a little bit
north of
philadelphia pennsylvania that area was
like all
owned by swedish people
now only a few years after this
after like all the swedish like
immigrants had come and kind of set up
their homesteads or whatever
the dutch in english started to arrive
and were kind of annoyed that all of the
best farmland had been taken by those
damn swedes
um so they were kind of pissed about
that
and they also were kind of pissed
because
i guess that they thought you know they
didn't know swedish obviously so they
and
you know the swedish people had
different customs to them had different
language to them so obviously that was
going to be like a cause of suspicion
so there was all just kind of like the
dutch and english were kind of like you
know being
[ __ ] faces like toward the swedes i
guess and like
not necessarily accusing all of them of
witchcraft other than in this one
particular case but
kind of like drumming up rumors about
them and that kind of thing
so comes the year 1683
there's this dude named henry dry street
which there's some great names like in
this [ __ ] day so i'm just gonna tell
you right now
henry dry street now his cows
stopped producing milk oh something's
wrong there
so first thing you think of which is
which is this is 17th century i mean
that's the first thing that i think of
they don't think of like a normal
[ __ ] reason like i'm not feeding them
the right thing or something you know
nope witches must be doing it so
he basically is so he almost immediately
like points the finger at his neighbor
margaret matson who
i guess had been rumored as being a
witch for a really long time
there's not a huge amount of their court
records of this which i read
and some other things but it's like
there's not a real
she had kind of been rumored to be a
witch for like a long time
reportedly but i'm not really sure why
other than she was swedish and
maybe people didn't like her for some
particular reason
maybe that was the only reason because i
do feel like that was kind of a
and we talked about this because we did
a show about the salem witch trials like
a while back i feel like that was
i read this really good book several it
was god probably like a long time ago
and it was called the devil in the shape
of a woman
and it was talking about how a lot of
victims
of witch trials were either
uh obviously poor women you know women
who didn't have any power
women who had [ __ ] that somebody else
wanted um
you know land or whatever um or women
who were
mentally ill couldn't fight back for
whatever reason so they always went
after like
either vulnerable women or women that
had [ __ ] that they wanted
you know what i mean women that didn't
have husbands didn't have protectors
didn't have anything like that
so i don't know so it seems like this
woman margaret matson she did have a
husband
they had like a substantial uh
land holding but i don't know if they
were like
wealthier than other people and people
wanted their land i don't really know
like i think the dutch and english did
kind of like want some of the swedes
land because they got all the best [ __ ]
because they were there first which you
know fair enough
um so it might have been that
but in any case so this dude's cows stop
making milk and he
is basically like hey margaret she's a
witch and she like [ __ ] cursed my
cows or whatever
now interestingly even though margaret
matson
i believe is the only one that has a
wikipedia entry there was another woman
who was also swedish
uh who was also put on trial as a witch
right next to margaret madsen and her
name was
yeshro hendrickson she also had a
husband named jacob i think it was or
jacob if you want to be all swedish
about it
um and so they stood trial together
now you know they so they get uh brought
to trial and as i
mentioned earlier the very famous
william penn who was a quaker
and who was the founder of the state of
pennsylvania
was actually the judge in this
particular case
so let's talk about okay so this is the
1680s
you get accused of witchcraft this is
kind of a big deal
obviously now nine ten years later
would be the whole salem witchcraft
trial i believe is 21 people ended up
getting killed
in that uh all of them were hanged
except for guys corey who was pressed to
death under stones famously
this trial didn't quite go the same way
and i think
that it's interesting i found it very
interesting
just from like uh from a cultural
standpoint at the time like
why this trial didn't go the same way as
the later one went on because
this one didn't really have the whole
hysteria behind it i feel like the whole
salem witch trial thing was just like
these teenage girls like everyone's a
witch witch witch and then everyone
started like accusing each other
and it turned into this whole like
[ __ ] feedback loop of
everyone accusing other people to save
their own ass and [ __ ] like that
whereas you didn't really get that so
much in this one and i feel like
maybe clearer heads prevailed and i'm
not saying that
these people were smarter and like
didn't believe that witches existed
because they totally did
but they didn't it didn't get to the
point of
this kind of you know
snowballing effect like you got in salem
you know what i mean like i said this
was the only one in pennsylvania as far
as i know
so um as i said
so when we're talking about witch trial
let's kind of go back a little bit
before we're talking about what are you
doing okay
i'm doing what i do dropping [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] drop where do you know where pookie
is
she just came in say hi and she left oh
okay i didn't see her
i didn't see her like open the door hey
you know since you [ __ ] up and just
[ __ ] stopped talking about the case i
want to say something real quick
okay so what do you want
the new mandalorian episode that came
out
last night was [ __ ] awesome all right
carl weathers is in it gina corino's in
it carl weather's directed
carl weathers directed it and man it was
[ __ ] i think it was the best episode
so far
i think it's my favorite so far it was
an action episode
and [ __ ] carl was [ __ ] he was
great in it
he's doing all kinds of cool [ __ ]
shooting down tire fighters from the
[ __ ] flying tank
that i had when i was a little kid the
troop transport all kinds of cool [ __ ]
happens in it
they find out more about i don't want to
spoil it but they find them more about
what they were doing baby yoda what they
were trying to do there
gina was looking [ __ ] great man she
looked [ __ ] big and she was [ __ ]
beating people's asses
and i love that [ __ ] movie because
it's not like they did with blood rain
or with [ __ ]
even a resident evil where they take a
pretty girl model and try to get you to
believe she can fly around kicking
people
no they take a [ __ ] girl who really
can't beat ass
and then they make her a [ __ ] a star
just like they used to
make me so happy to say that you're
right because that's what the old 80s
action stars were because she's like all
buffy yeah [ __ ]
carl was carl was not pretending to be a
badass
he was a badass that was the same with
[ __ ]
arnold and all the other badasses from
the 80s you got to start off as a badass
and then you make a movie
and that's what they did with gina she
already is a badass then she makes it
yeah so they put her in a bit so when
she's like beating the [ __ ] out of
people you buy it you're like yep
because she's she can do this she's as
big or bigger than they are
she's not that big but she but she's
you know she's the size of a of a big
woman you know uh
but she's she fights for for a living
so she can beat people's asses and you
just
you buy it so much more than having that
little redheaded russian girl running
around [ __ ] kicking people in the
face from resident evil i mean she's
cute
that girl from fifth element i mean
unless you got magic powers or something
it's like that's not reality
like a tiny skinny little model girl is
not going to kick a big
there's just no foundation there's just
not enough
they're not big enough there's just not
enough ass behind those fists
it's just not you've got to have some
weight behind you to do
that kind of [ __ ] when you can pick
somebody up off the ground you're [ __ ]
and that's what happens when you're 120
pound little supermodel the dude just
picks you up
and then that's why children can't beat
your ass because you can pick them up
they can't punch hard enough they're not
[ __ ] because you can just pull them
up by the hair and they would just
yeah well part of a punch or a kick is
actually pushing against the ground and
into you
if you can pick somebody up they're
instantly weaker they don't have the
leverage
so but gina can't beat people's asses
and they show her do it you know what i
mean you go yeah she could do that she
does that [ __ ]
but what what really [ __ ]
what really [ __ ] set me off last
night was just
being assured that carl is on a [ __ ]
good
project you know what i mean yeah that's
his career
he's doing his career [ __ ] didn't
just because man i was [ __ ]
i was i was a fan of carl going back to
the action jackson days
remember action jackson yeah they never
did make a sequel to that
i didn't i like that one and [ __ ]
predator one and everything
and he's not fading away that
[ __ ] is getting better
and i just you know makes me feel it
makes me feel good like maybe when i'm
old i'll be a bad [ __ ] too
because he does look cool as an old man
he looks good i like the beard i gotta
say yeah
yeah he looks good as an old man he was
good he looked and i like that he's just
like letting the beard be gray he's just
like [ __ ] it
i have a grey beard it's a great
character it looks good great character
and that series i'm just
i believe in the mandalorian series i
don't like disney i didn't like those
new star wars movies but
i didn't think they were i didn't think
they were authentic star wars
even the prequels they were kind of
authentic but i didn't like them as much
as the originals
this is real star wars i'm just saying
mandalorian that's real star wars
well tonally it is very easy that's star
wars i grew up with and can we talk
about
baby yoda wasn't in this one as much but
can we talk about
the cookies go ahead i mean
like i said i don't want to spoil it for
anybody but because baby yoda was only
in it for a couple minutes because he
kind of got dropped off because he
wasn't
you know he didn't want to you know
mandalorian didn't want him to like be
involved in all like fighting and [ __ ]
so he kind of dropped him off somewhere
but yeah um
it's very funny because yeah it's like
baby you would have all these cookies
and then like later on spoiler alert
spoiler alert
um he ended up like kind of puking him
up because he ate too many
yeah and it was funny because the night
before we watched that episode
pookie had eaten too many treats and
threw up next to her tree plate
and was like very upset about it and was
like telling tom just like look what
happened you have to give me
new treats and you have to clean this up
it's like i didn't mean to
so it's like so i told her this morning
we were having mommy pooky time
i was like it's okay like baby yoda also
ate too many cookies
i want her to be like you know that's
like that's like her hero
tom sounds like my son but even then
but even he thought twice when boba
showed up
uh bubba fett didn't show up and uh i
don't know what she's talking about that
wasn't in the mandalorian
um and he got um tiva talking about
action jackson and
[ __ ] vanity yeah remember vanity yeah
she was [ __ ] yeah she was hot yeah
one of prince's yeah i wonder what
happened to her she still i don't know
i don't know actually anybody know what
happened i saw action jackson in the
theater and [ __ ] loved it
and was it's not on cable i think i saw
it in the theater it was [ __ ] awesome
and uh it was a 80s
action movie you know like like an
arnold schwarzenegger type movie
and i i said i was like man there's
going to be a sequel oh man i can't wait
for the sequel it never came out
oh she died oh she died yeah okay vanity
all right yeah she was in the movies i
remember it i haven't seen it forever
i should actually get it and see it
again but i saw in the theater and loved
it
yeah too bad too bad they never made
another one
well it's probably one of those things i
feel like every movie that did business
even back in the 80s
if it did like really good business they
started talking about doing a sequel
right away
but it doesn't always work out you know
it's like because [ __ ] gets like passed
from studio to studio
it's like they get funding it falls
through a lot so she died in 2016 a
kidney failure
yeah i didn't know that [ __ ] yeah that
sucks
what happened to is apollonia still
around her yeah i don't know
the star wars prequels should have been
better that's what [ __ ] roy said yeah
they were all right yeah it was they
were like i said i've said this before i
liked him better than the prequel so
the prequels i really still the prequels
were
i still do not like the prequels and i
have given them
so many chances like i watched them
again like a year or two ago and i'm
just like okay i'm gonna like
get rid of all my misperceptions i'm
gonna watch this
and i'm gonna find and then like i
watched them and i still hated them
i went on i went on a rant one time
about the prequels
no you rant i went on a pr i went on a
rant to the prequels one time and jenny
was like yeah that's right because i
came up
with the solution of what what it should
have been well you rewrote it in a way
that i
thought it would have been
vader and the [ __ ] jedi and the
republic and all the ship
it should have been a civil war between
two groups that both thought they were
right and both had
evidence that the others were [ __ ]
traitors
vader should have went out and hunted
down the jedi because he thought they
were traitors and then later what it
should have been revealed to him that he
had been duped that they were actually
the good guys and that he was on the
wrong side that's what it should have
been are we the best and then the
then the guilt was used against him
that's how it should have been
well that would have been a lot more
cohesive and that was the way it was
described by obi-wan that
vader had hunted down the jedi in the
jedi civil war
that's what he said in in a new hope
um but there could have been a lot
better
but i will say this somebody
took those three movies and edited it
down into two movies and it's a lot
it was a lot better i watched it and it
was like it's a lot better
there's some [ __ ] missing that person
yeah the problem was an
edit problem more than anything else
like i said
editing is very underrated as a skill
yeah but the the three prequels can be
added
the three prequels can be edited into
two movies and that it works out a lot
better
sheila anne said tom two episodes back
boba fett showed up at the end
he was the bald onlooker it's the
original actor too
i didn't notice it yeah i didn't either
i didn't notice it [ __ ] man i totally
missed that now we have to go back and
like watch him again
god damn it it's a good series i like
that series
i do too and like i said i think that as
much as i love the first season i think
i'm liking this one more yeah
well it gets back to the heart of what
star it's more monster-centric
which i like star wars was nothing but a
east meets west
[ __ ] movie it was kurosawa and
[ __ ] spaghetti western put together
it was
samurai and spaghetti western together
in one movie that's what star wars was
that's what mandalorian is i mean you
know
i feel so much [ __ ] spaghetti western
in certain areas and other things like
80s action it's just it's just
that's that was the tone of the
originals
well like i said you can see that john
favreau the guy that he's the showrunner
yeah you know he's the dude from
swingers and that guy
yeah but um and he's in the marvel
movies but he like
really understood the essence of
original star wars
it's essentially like a western or like
you said like a samurai samurai
and evidently from what i saw last night
carl understands what star wars is
because he directed that and that's that
was spot on
yeah like i said i think this might have
been my favorite episode
and that's that's saying something
because i've really liked it he had the
action right
the acting right the story the [ __ ]
the edit was perfect there was never any
[ __ ]
dead spots in the movie the flow of that
episode was great
i hope i hope they let him direct a
couple more episodes at least this
season
well and i'm telling you too that i
think a lot of people complained even
going back so far as return of the jedi
people complained about too much cutesy
[ __ ] because you know like the ewoks
oh you just did that for the toys and
[ __ ] like that but i think
mandalorian shows how you can do cutesy
it's gotta be right
but you can do it correctly the timing
has to be right
the [ __ ] soundtrack the the the
visual cues and the audio cues it has to
be right
it has to fit in the tone the original
edit of a return of the jedi the audio
cues were wrong
especially during the ewok scenes it was
too light-hearted
too stupid remember how [ __ ] crazy
yeah
it's weird because i i guess i didn't
notice it at the time but i when i
watched it again later
i was kind of like i still love return
of the jedi don't get me wrong but i
feel like a lot of [ __ ] that people
complained about in the prequels and the
sequels
was also present in return of the jedi
and people
kind of give that a pass most versions
the return of the jedi that's out there
now though
have all the extra [ __ ] which they have
they had some extra [ __ ]
but they also changed the [ __ ] the
soundtrack
that too so it didn't have the [ __ ] up
ewok music
all right with the ewoks are dying and
they're playing kind of almost [ __ ]
cutesy music during it it didn't make
any [ __ ] sense
yeah the tone was wrong but like i said
you know the nice thing about the
mandalorian is they have like funny [ __ ]
and cutesy [ __ ] but it works
like i said i could watch a whole
[ __ ] series about yoda
doing baby yoda [ __ ] it was cutesy [ __ ]
it was more realistic cutesy [ __ ] his
weight would be
well he's just acting like a baby yeah
just act like a baby the [ __ ] that was
in
the combat scene of the [ __ ] of the
ewoks
wasn't right that the sound where the
music wasn't right for
also some of the stuff that was
happening on the sale barge was too
[ __ ] cutesy
you know just going back to the [ __ ]
hold on what's the restroom
you know the deal go ahead go ahead talk
about the goddamn thing i'm trying to
talk about the goddamn thing
sophie says one of your next special
episodes needs to be a full on no topic
i know right it's like i feel like all
of our episodes are no topic episodes
like i feel like we cover the [ __ ] but
it takes a while for us to get around to
it because that's just
that's just how we roll i'm sorry i'm
sorry if you're new here and it's like
you don't know
like how it goes but that's how it goes
so okay so while he's not here and i can
like talk about witchcraft for a second
so going back to kind of like your
original statutes about
witchcraft um so 17th century england
king james the first uh who very
famously did
you know king james bible that was his
version and everything like that
in 1604 he wrote very specifically
this um you know this kind of statute
about witchcraft so he says and this is
a quote
an act against conjuration witchcraft
and dealing with evil and wicked spirits
the penalty for practicing of invocation
or conjuration
etc conjuration or invocation whereby
any person is killed or lamed
declaring by witchcraft where anything
is hidden procuring unlawful love
etc so you know love potions uh the
second offense felony no forfeiture of
dour inheritance
trial of appear of the realm now this is
an interesting
statute because it doesn't necessarily i
feel like
since christianity became like the kind
of major
uh you know thing in law at the time you
know it it has that whole thing from i
think it's from exodus like thou shalt
not suffer a witch or a sorcerers or
whatever to live
so death penalty was usually the thing
but this statute in particular which is
from 1604 seems kind of like much vaguer
and i think that the [ __ ] that he said
at the end
about not forfeiting the inheritance or
anything
i think that was something because prior
to that if you had got executed for
witchcraft or what have you
you know the church or the state or
whatever would take your [ __ ]
right so i feel like the fact that they
had that statute in 1604
i think that was almost kind of like
maybe encouraging other family members
to knock on you for being a witch
because they know will
they'd still get your stuff you know
what i mean because it wasn't a case of
well you know grandma got executed for
being a witch and like the state took
all her [ __ ] we don't get anything
but now it's like well a grandma gets
executed for a witch
will still get her [ __ ] so yeah she's
totally a witch we will totally like
[ __ ]
you know testify against her which is
[ __ ] up but i feel like that was
probably like the impetus behind that
i could be wrong but i'm a cynic you
know what i mean
so um now the thing about it though and
we talked about this a little bit on our
uh salem witch trial show
where there was kind of a thing where
consorting with the devil
being is how it's something that's
usually
lit puke out why she was like she wanted
to go outside and
say look at you look at you here yeah
little dude oatmeal he has a whole
last time he went to sam's you got like
whole big boxes i get a case of them
get a whole case of a screen you're
lucky i don't like those
they're only like five bucks for six
bucks for a case you might as well get a
case
you know 400 pounds later
you don't eat them all at once you know
well i don't
yeah man you're gonna in like five years
you're gonna be one of those
southerners he's gonna be like one of
those people that can't get out of bed
and they have to like use a forklift to
like [ __ ]
okay like i said beautiful i
i like a lot of little debbies but
oatmeal cream buys for some reason even
it seems to be like a lot of people's
favorites but i'm just
no i think because it's got like
marshmallow in the middle i'm not a big
marshmallow fan
it's free it's not free you paid for
those well you know
it's cheap i mean i like oatmeal cookies
yeah
but the oatmeal cookies on there are
kind of mushy and like i said in the
middle
soft oatmeal yeah man i like some
oatmeal cookies with like some [ __ ]
this is like something high class
brilliant nuts and [ __ ] in there
it's like some high-class british [ __ ]
going back to the honky motherland
in [ __ ] uk meanwhile all the british
are being like don't blame us
for that we don't have that [ __ ] they
don't have that [ __ ] over there
i pretended i don't even think they have
oatmeal the duke of cornwall made this
stuff
it was his recipe special recipe tom's
history
tom's revisionist history
went directly to mississippi i don't
even know i mean
please like correct me if i'm wrong but
when i was in the uk i don't remember
ever seeing
like oatmeal cookies i don't think
that's a big thing
over there no that's an american thing i
think i think it's an american thing
maybe not but i feel like i didn't
really see much of that over there
they don't have little debbies for sure
but like i said i'm not [ __ ] on
little debbies i love little debbies i
love zebra cakes i love peanut like the
nutty buddy things or whatever i love
those
i love the donut sticks even even though
you got to dip them in [ __ ] because
they're kind of dry
i'm talking about how good rogue one was
rogue one was good i liked roblox i
really liked drunk one actually
solo was okay too although so bad as i
thought
solo was good i just feel like it was
unnecessary
that's all it was i thought it was gonna
be really bad it wasn't that bad no it
wasn't bad
it was enjoyable like i said i just
didn't think it needed to be that's not
a story that really needed to be
told i think i could have told a better
house well they could have done
um i mean i feel like there were other
you know characters whose backstories
would be more interesting
how he lost all that [ __ ] to [ __ ] job
on how the price got put on his head
that's what the [ __ ] does well i mean
that could have been the whole movie
that's what i'm saying yeah i feel like
the only thing that about solo
i just felt like it was too much fan
service they were just kind of like hey
everything that he mentioned in star
wars we're gonna like explain all of
that i don't i don't think they needed
to do that
that's why i'm saying that's why i think
it's unnecessary i don't think i don't
remember them ever saying anything about
the price on his head
yeah they didn't really go that much
into that haven't gotten that
job i mean they did a little bit but not
i don't know i just feel like it wasn't
that it should have been
that should have been the focus of the
whole story but rogue one was actually
really good
because the thing about star wars was
that you know at the beginning like leia
has the plans and you don't really know
like the backstory about
how she got them or like where they came
from or anything like that so i feel
like that was a good
angle to explore and that was like a
really because man i don't know if you
guys saw rogue one but like [ __ ]
everybody dies pretty much but you know
what i mean like
so i thought that was like a good story
to tell the solo backstory i just feel
he doesn't really need a backstory like
he kind of mentioned some [ __ ]
and you know that's fine i don't i don't
think that really needed to be told like
i said i would rather see
a backstory about vader
but not him as a kid in the pod race and
all that kind of crap
like i said i would rather watch what
you said yeah
about him like kind of discovering
the dark side and like going to like the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i would watch that i had this idea
of a
darth vader movie where he's already in
the suit
he's enslaved to the emperor he's being
kept alive by the emperor through the
[ __ ] force he's actually kind of like
a living
corpse in a damn machine all right
that's why he couldn't betray the
emperor
because if he kills the emperor he dies
okay
because there's a lot of [ __ ] that was
said there's a lot of [ __ ] that was said
in those movies that leads me to believe
that the emperor was
brought him back to life and was keeping
him alive with the force
i had an idea where it had a movie where
darth vader would go out and he's
[ __ ]
searching for [ __ ] sith relics and
artifacts
hidden in old scenes [ __ ] sounds like
a good movie to try to find some [ __ ]
sounds like a good movie
to locate ways of [ __ ] stopping his
dependency on the [ __ ] emperor or
louis said somebody should have made a
lando movie
which also i would have watched yeah
that'd have been good depending on who
they had to play in him
because i mean they don't like lando
doesn't have much of a backstory so it'd
be like really fascinating to look into
his [ __ ]
i really made like an indiana jones
movie that had
that head of darth vader him trying to
find these yeah
see i i think that's the way to go yeah
he has to sneak away from the empire
dark side
villains he has to lie
about where he's going to go to go to
these [ __ ]
forgotten planets where the sith used to
be and there's all these [ __ ] ruined
temples and
he's got to get down in there and find
some stuff and then he find he talks to
sith
ghosts that tell him [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ] would have happened
that's how i would have wrote it see you
could have made it like almost like a
straight up horror movie
yeah it'd been a horror movie basically
yeah see that
ghosts that told him [ __ ] and then he'd
have to [ __ ] turn
sith ghosts and like exercise and sith
ghosts to get his hands on some [ __ ] and
it'd have been a big mind [ __ ]
yeah see i don't watch that where a sith
ghost almost tries to possess him in one
part you know what i mean i've had it
come up with all kinds of weird
paranormal [ __ ] scary [ __ ]
michael schaefer says you should read
the book the rise of vader
i haven't never read it so maybe that's
something along the lines of what you're
talking about it would have had a bunch
of paranormals and occult stuff in it
see that's yeah i think that would have
made that that
really yeah i think although like i said
i did like rogue one because i liked
that they kind of went into that [ __ ]
and it was like bleak
yeah like not bleak because you know it
turned out
kind of okay because you know how the
next movie goes yeah
but i liked that they showed like the
sacrifice that led up to that
you know what i mean i like that they
went there that was like that was cool
to me
and it was like a war and it was like a
war maybe we gotta get on with the show
jenny we're talking about witchcraft
this ain't a star
star wars show everybody's talking about
star wars
sophie said that we should do a no topic
show on like one of these days
just yeah
people are actually leaving the chat
because we're talking about star wars
well yeah well like i said okay so you
can't say [ __ ] them but you know
well i'm not gonna say that i'm just
saying like people have free will they
can do
they can leave if they want they can
like later like share and subscribe
they can skip hit the like button people
hit the like button they can skip
through the [ __ ]
i'm too old to care about that crack
kind of crap you know what i mean
i'm trying to manage i'm trying to
manage this [ __ ] i'm gonna get another
drink here in a bit
oh you're still in your first one yeah
okay i'm on the second one
so as i said we were talking i was
talking a little bit about like we went
into this some on the
uh on the salem witch trial show but i
was talking about how
in uh the early 17th century
1604 king james and he kind of came up
with the whole
you know thing about witchcraft and how
he made it okay
for uh if somebody got executed for
witchcraft like their family would still
get their [ __ ] and i
said that it was probably because they
wanted like the relatives to like
testify against them you know that's
just my cynical brain talking
um but as i said we're talking about
spectral evidence which
was kind of a big thing in the salem
witch trials where
that was something that was allowed
because i guess the rationale was
that since the devil could pretty much
do anything or make you believe anything
like
even make somebody look like they were
innocent
that any kind of like spectral evidence
quote unquote that you had
of like supernatural kind of shenanigans
was okay
so i feel like they gave a lot of leeway
in witchcraft
situations which they wouldn't give
necessarily in another
type of trial because
as i said their reasoning was well the
devil can like be witch people and he
can
make people um you know say certain
things and make them look like they're
innocent or they can
you know they can deceive people or
whatever so it's
so i think that they gave the courts
and whoever was prosecuting witchcraft
like a lot of leeway
in saying well pretty much
whatever is all right like i think that
was one of the
things that was kind of like the impetus
for all of the horrible [ __ ] that
happened because
anything went pretty much you know what
i mean
so um it so it got to a point where
pretty much just somebody accusing you
of witchcraft was enough
to like get you put in [ __ ] jail you
would get tortured because they thought
that that was
a good way of extracting information and
um
and not just a way of like getting you
to say what they wanted you to say
just to get you to stop doing what you
were doing
so they basically said and this is
um a quote from a particular you know
thing that came out back then that if
the quote was if there was any like
likelihood and suspicion
and common fame like if a lot of people
said you were a witch
that was proof enough quote unquote so
that's
pretty much all you had to do is like
bring in a bunch of people like yeah i
heard that person
was a witch and that was all you needed
to say which is
terrifying so um
another thing like i said i'm taking a
lot of the information from this one
particular like long article because
this was like the most
substantive uh [ __ ] that i could find in
this particular case because like i said
this is
a much lesser known case um
he says and i quote this kind of made me
laugh in a weird way
enhanced interrogations were encouraged
enhanced interrogations meaning
torture obviously yeah um
and if the [ __ ] about it was that they
tortured you
but then if you confessed then you were
in trouble
but if you didn't confess you were also
in trouble because then they would just
burn you or hang you anyway they
continue to torture you
and or continue to show so it was like
you know it was lose lose
it was lose for everybody so it so it's
kind of like frightening how
reason didn't really prevail in this
whole [ __ ] time period and like i
said that's kind of something we talked
about when we talked about the
uh salem witch trials so
their reasoning was they're like look
witchcraft is something that is
conducted in secret so
ergo you don't have any witnesses to it
so just the fact that somebody heard
somebody saying
that maybe you were doing some
witchcraft [ __ ]
that was like enough to at least bring
you and get you tortured and [ __ ]
and like i said once you were brought in
for torture you're pretty much hosed
either way
because if you confessed you were in
trouble and if you didn't confess you
were all so much trouble i was always
under the impression that the whole
witchcraft thing was [ __ ] i think
okay when you go back and you look at
the motives
of what people did from other eras and
they would do some crazy [ __ ] but if you
were actually to read into the culture
of the time a lot of time it made sense
a lot of the crazy [ __ ] they did made
sense during those days
it's just that there were ulterior
motives behind what they were doing
well i mentioned that earlier i'm
talking about that book i think a lot of
times the witchcraft thing was it was a
convenient way of getting rid of people
you didn't like
and well you could make a bunch of money
off of it i'm not saying they didn't
believe in witchcraft though because i
totally believe they did i think some
people did but
most people didn't i think the people
that had the ability to start a huge
witch trial
were also the same people that were able
to profit off of it
and it was a way they weren't going to
question they weren't able and they were
going to get rid of their enemies
so i think what it was is it was it was
a sham
they're like look we got this old woman
she's living out there when nobody
really don't like her she's you know
when she's got some land we kind of yeah
we want that land and she needs to go
you know what i mean [ __ ] she's not
doing anybody any good right let's
go ahead weird yeah let's go ahead and
get rid of her and i'll make a couple
grand
and my buddy will come in and he'll make
a couple grand and we'll whip everybody
up we'll have a big [ __ ] festival and
sell a bunch of food during her [ __ ]
execution it'll be great
that's what i think that's what i think
that that's what i think it was this is
why
when she's gone i'll be able to go in
there and buy the land and and [ __ ]
you'll get it in a discount
and i'll buy the land with the money
that i rose from [ __ ] killing her
and you know i mean from this those food
i think in a lot of cases i think it was
kind of what it was i think it was more
about that
because when you try to when you look at
their methods of investigation and their
methods that they use to
prove things even a person of the 1600s
in the 1500s would know that that's
[ __ ]
they weren't stupid i know they weren't
stupid
because a lot of the other [ __ ] that
they did made perfect sense
i think what it was is more more than
anything else they were evil
that's what i think it was they were
just evil
well yeah they were just looking out for
them they were looking out for number
one and they had ways of doing it
they're playing on the prejudices and
the [ __ ]
fears and the superstitions and as i
mentioned earlier they're going after
people that are essentially powerless
yeah and it was kind of like a [ __ ]
eugenics you know i mean these are
single women they're old they've
outlived their usefulness and they're on
land that we need
like i said they're weird like see this
is why i would never invent a time
machine if i went back to this time
period i would be burned as a witch in
like
within five seconds oh yeah big time
well
that also kept it because i can't keep
my mouth shut it kept everybody in line
if you [ __ ] said some [ __ ]
against the power structure you were
dead all right
and the power structure was a bunch of
judges and a bunch of churches
in in this era in that place
and i think they knew they were full of
[ __ ]
it's just that they didn't want to give
up power would you some of them did
here's the thing i feel like some of
them did know that it was [ __ ]
and i kind of want to go into that a
little bit too because of the way that
this trial
in particular turned out and like some
things that william penn said like
during the
trial um i feel like though
that the main thing was that there was a
danger
if you came forward and said hey this is
[ __ ] there's
either there's no such things as witches
or i don't think this particular person
is a witch
then you would get accused of being a
witch i think that's one thing that
happened in salem that kind of like
contributed to the whole snowballing
effect was that anybody that came
forward and said hey
like i don't think this is cool would i
mean oh well you must be a witch too and
then they'd be like well well [ __ ] me
yeah but you know there was some [ __ ]
that i read a long time ago i haven't
researched this
recently but i remember during one of
these little [ __ ] rich [ __ ] panics
where um a lot of it a lot of it had to
do with your personal charisma too
they descended on i remember in one case
they descended on some
attractive young woman and they were
gonna getting ready to accuse of a witch
and a witch hunter
stuck a needle in her all right and she
didn't react
and um yeah they said well that means
she's a witch
and a well-known
very respected military militia officer
stood forward and said wait a minute he
says
can you do that to anyone and will they
not react
and he made that witch hunter put that
same needle
into another person i think it was the
judge it's like you got any more
and he didn't react let's see that [ __ ]
so the court
threw that out that particular one all
right so he's safe
plus she was young and cute she was
young and cute
and mentally ill very different like
right they let that one go yeah okay
so a lot of it had to do with charisma
so then the witch hunter turns on
what an old woman of course
because she's here to kill somebody
[ __ ] tests on her and then that
military officer did not stand up to
protect her
of course he didn't right but was he a
coward no
i think he was wise because what would
happen is the witch hunter would have
started turning on that [ __ ] officer
and they would have killed him they
would eventually prove him
as being a witch well that's cool that
was kind of their thing
so you were just lucky to save a couple
of people
and like i said you were safe sticking
up for somebody that was like young and
hot yeah
right because you stood up for some
crazy right
yeah and that kind of [ __ ] then you'd
get [ __ ] too
that kind of goes along goes back to
what i was saying
a lot of it had to do with your charisma
and who you were
and what value you were to the society a
good-looking young woman
single no she would be eating she could
still have babies
she'd be easier to save there's a you
know so they started to focus on people
that were not easy to save
the people who were past their prime the
people who were not married
the people you know what i mean who
looked weird yeah people who were
disposable
so i think deep down
during all this [ __ ] most of the people
knew it was [ __ ]
but they were scared of death well yeah
everybody's saying
you would never know nowadays because i
feel like most of the people that
knew it was [ __ ] yeah were they're
like well they're
i'm not gonna say anything because i'm
gonna get my ass killed
and it's like they couldn't they were
illiterate they didn't write anything
just like
twitter today you know i mean [ __ ]
people accusing everybody on twitter
certain things that you can't prove or
disapprove you jump in the twitter mess
you're gonna get [ __ ] up it was like
that in fact mango said um
didn't they go after midwives also yeah
that was that was another big thing um
in that book i read i can't remember who
wrote it but it was called the devil in
the shape of a woman
i think was the name of it it was like
an older book i got it from the library
like years and years ago
and that was kind of like what the the
author was saying
that a lot of the women that were chosen
not only like kind of marginalized women
in the sense that they were older
they were you know either poor or they
had
[ __ ] that other people wanted or they
were mentally ill or you know
or they talked too much or they were too
outspoken or whatever but midwives were
another big
demographic that was targeted sure like
a lot of people didn't really trust them
well the midwives a lot of times were
older women who weren't married so then
there you go just practicable disposable
exactly they're like well you can't have
babies and you don't have a man
to protect you and that's
shitty but most of the time
not every time but most of the time they
seem to go for
that town's most vulnerable that's who
they were going well yeah that's what i
was saying
yeah well that's it's the easiest thing
to do the easiest one because there's
difficult you know and it doesn't
disrupt it doesn't disrupt the town yeah
because everybody hates that [ __ ]
anyway
she crazy she's weird whatever [ __ ]
um
the uh salem was actually
sticks out as an anomaly because it was
a bunch of young people and a bunch of
valuable people that were being killed
and it really didn't stop until what was
the judge's wife got con
accused and then oh yeah once it got to
that all started because of some well in
the same way it started with kind of
some privileged
teenagers teenage girls yeah which
like i said not women were not super
valuable but teenage girls were
valuable in the sense that they would be
someone's wives someday and would
reproduce and whatever so it's like
i feel like they're they were maybe
given a lot more leeway than
and their parents were important people
also
so if they said hey this goes to this
old like old hag in the town that nobody
likes is like poking me and like
you know like putting curses on me and
[ __ ]
it's like no one's to question that yeah
louis brought that up
it was either the governor's wife or the
judge's wife yeah it was something like
that but somebody powerful's wife got
accused and then oh we got to show you
that okay that's it okay no more [ __ ]
witch hunts
yeah as long as we were just killing
like you know haitian slave women
yeah like older ladies and stuff that
was fine but yeah
not that not the upper-class white
chicks oh no
and then like everybody's like then we
have to stop doing it so
yeah you can just see the one with a
powerful rich husband no you're never
right
that's exactly yeah it wasn't the women
it was the husbands that they were
well yeah because nobody i mean this is
horrible to say a woman was really worth
what her husband was yeah
a woman was not considered like a full
person i mean they couldn't vote they
couldn't
own property they couldn't do anything
they were just like an adjunct
yeah now i gotta [ __ ] set some [ __ ]
straight there here though
we're talking about religious colonies
this is before the united states this is
all this is [ __ ] you know
fifteen sixteen hundreds all right well
yes colon really during that time
yeah that wasn't really the case with
women
say like uh later uh [ __ ] secular
women uh women that were white women
that were in
indian tribes which that was far more
common than people realize
like considering the lots of white
people went went engine is what they
called it i totally would have done that
yeah hell yeah you did not it would have
been so much better
you did not want if you were in the new
world you did not want to live
in the anglo or european lifestyle or
culture
uh during that time they it was bad it
was very religious very
restrictive nope i'd have to run away
from there like screaming
crazy ass rules there was no such thing
as a us constitution or human rights or
anything they were theocracies
like i said i'd have been accused of a
witch of like in within a couple of
minutes and i just like run off and join
the native americans
the united states constitution was
heavily influenced by native american
culture
the whole concept of well in the
european enlightenment yeah and the
european alignment
particularly france but the whole idea
of like tribal democracies and different
and ideas of rights and things was
actually kind of
it was the enlightenment but it was also
they were seeing it confirmed
in native american lifestyles
oh in the united states [ __ ] really
your social status and what your birth
and royal blood none of that made
it none of that made a bit of [ __ ]
difference those [ __ ] still starved
you had to get it like you live in the
united states you had to go out and
[ __ ]
work and get some [ __ ] food and shoot
some animals and plant some crops and
[ __ ]
fine you actually had to do [ __ ] you
couldn't just lay back and [ __ ] get
some gold from the king because you had
noble birth it didn't work here
you had to be practical america was
about practicality that's what it was
about
and survival skills and talent america
always recognized talent
that's really and when it wasn't
recognizing talent
it was america betraying its own [ __ ]
values and that took
centuries for the [ __ ] to work itself
out i always thought to myself that the
native americans must have thought it
was hilarious
because they'd been living here for
thousands and thousands of years yeah
when the europeans first came and
probably like expected there to be like
[ __ ]
i don't know holiday ends or some [ __ ]
like not like
you know the equivalent of holidays back
then they were just kind of like wait
what do you mean we have to like [ __ ]
well you look at roanoke and some of the
early colonies they failed because there
wasn't a government structure to tell
them what to do
um they were used to that back in europe
um those colonies vanished a lot of them
it took a couple times to get them to
actually they know where they go well
they all went
indian they joined indian tribes it was
like i said i feel like i would have
done that
there was no agricultural seems like the
best yeah the best prospect
yeah yeah and um
you know you [ __ ] john smith and
miles standish and all those guys they
[ __ ] wrote about
and even like sacagawea and the guys
later on that went and explored the west
they all wrote about those
indian tribes they were all different
they were all different nations
uh they knew their [ __ ] man they were on
top of the [ __ ] game and they were at
the top
of the food chain in in in the american
continent
you couldn't live the year the 1600s
1500s european way in the united
in well it was a completely different it
wouldn't work there was no
infrastructure
climate it was a complete like you said
there was no infrastructure here there
was no
yeah it just wasn't it wasn't remotely
the same
squanto was an indian who came back from
europe he went to there were indians in
europe that's another thing that people
don't understand
indians went to europe yeah okay boats
would take them
then they'd go back to [ __ ] john
smith
[ __ ] met squanto squanto had just
come back from europe he says yeah my
people got wiped out in a plague and
[ __ ]
he was telling his people his tribe
about europe and stone buildings they
didn't believe him
they're like what what no way yeah so
squanto was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and john smith was the [ __ ] and
um
well i don't remember where i was going
with that of course i'm drinking it's
just
straight up what squanto what
yeah america was a mixture of all these
different ways of doing things
and it took centuries for it to work out
but
you know for you people who are not
americans you know we got people back
into hockey motherland
going all the way back into romania
listening to us you know
nosferatu listening to us the the thing
that was
the main force behind americanism was
just practicality
that's all it was well you had to be
very practical louis says
idealism and ideology didn't work too
much here
uh it was just [ __ ] that worked [ __ ]
that actually put food on the table is
what rose to the top in america yeah
it's like are you guys just gonna do
this jesusy [ __ ] or are we just gonna
like go get some food
right exactly like i don't have time for
this [ __ ] right now
and a lot of it success a lot of the
success of america has a lot to do with
the native american nations that were
here before
there's a lot of mythology about how
that [ __ ] went down
most of it was admixture most peop
white people and indians marrying each
other was really the main thing that
went on for a long time
white women running off to join [ __ ]
indian tribes like i said you can't
blame them
yeah [ __ ] white dudes and they're the
seminole indians here in florida
like in jackson was pissed at him
because he says how can they call
themselves indians they're
they're all irish well they're they were
mixed that's right yeah they were all
mixed it was largely mixed
they were mixed native american and
european native american european which
is irish and spanish and they were also
africans black people also in the
seminole
nation and they were all breeding
together
and the seminole nation also had slaves
which was weird
when you think about they had african
slaves even though some of us then some
of the
seminole slave holders were were black
too
it was it wasn't really a in that
particular
the seminals were weird it was it was a
strange it was like a mad max truck yeah
it's like a conglomerate
conglomerate and they were working as
mercenaries for the spanish empire
not the british empire they flipped
later they changed sides to the to the
american side the history of the
seminole
yeah indians is like because florida and
seminole indians are like very
intertwined but it's like it's really
fascinating i hear these kids talk about
native american history and american
history and
they're using broad generalizations each
native american nation had its own
history and its own destiny
and they were all very different it's
like you can't com you couldn't compare
them like you couldn't compare
england to romania they're both european
but there's well yes
well and it's the same thing native
american tribes they were they were all
completely different nations exactly and
they were
even more diverse than europe or africa
even more diverse
in terms of culture that was all kind of
yeah there was just lots of them
you know it's just they weren't all the
same race
they weren't all the same race well yeah
some of them were kind of more like the
aztecs
other ones were kind of more like clovis
people which were part irish people that
walked across ice shelves
some of them might have even had for all
we know well they know that
some of them kind of had chinese style
at ancestry
possibly russian type stuff mixed in
there too there's just
no there's just no talent they were they
were not all the same ethnic group they
weren't all the same race
i do feel like a lot of native american
tribes had a lot of asian
dna well because they were descended
from
asians that walked across the ice shelf
right and there was also not all this
[ __ ]
genocidal [ __ ] hatred that's all
[ __ ] too because if you go back to
the 15 16
1700s literature that white
people wrote about the indians it was
nothing but just damn [ __ ]
man crush all they did was just talk
about how much stronger they were and
how much better looking they were
at least back then they knew that like
the native americans were better
i'm talking about how [ __ ] how badass
the mohawk were and you know and other
stuff so there
there wasn't any of this weird [ __ ]
anti-indian sentiment until the very
late 1800s well that was a literature
that was way way late and that was at
the
end of the indian era or the native
american era
and those are just the very few holdouts
the rest of them had all married white
people and gotten jobs and [ __ ] by that
time
yeah a lot more racial and that was and
that was generations before
generations so for generations you know
you go back into any of our dna we ours
families have been here for centuries
you go back into any of our dna you're
going to find native american dna in
there
well mine's only you're you're
definitely right mine's only three my
great grandparents were new yeah
and that happened for the hunters the
man
they were black feet the man the nation
the mandan
nation went extinct because they married
white people
they all got married they were the they
were my mom's side is english irish
but my dad's side is native american
yeah
like i said my great grandparents who i
knew i knew my great-grandmother my
great-grandfather [ __ ] off like before
i was born yeah
he took off but yeah but they were
native americans and then you can go
back to the mid-1800s the early part of
the 1800s
and look at photos of the american army
down in texas and they're all in they're
all indians
a lot of people don't know that they're
wearing american uniforms they were
whole divisions
of american cavalry and they were all
indians
well like i said before history is
always more
shaded yeah it's a lot more varied than
people
like i understand like when you're in
school for example and they have to
teach you
world like i took a [ __ ] class in
high school i was thinking about this
the other day
world history how the [ __ ] can you cover
that in nine months
you know good luck with that yeah but
and and honestly the world history class
i
it was mostly european history i gotta
say like a little bit of african and
asian like sprinkled in there but it was
mostly european history
but even then it's like how are we gonna
cover i feel like all we covered was
wars
you know like the major wars but you
didn't like cover like the interesting
[ __ ] like wars are interesting but
i always find this is why i really like
one of my favorite genres of nonfiction
books i know this is kind of like
like i said like kind of off topic but
one of my favorite genres of non-fiction
books
is a history of something that i never
thought about having a history one of my
favorite
nonfiction books ever this is totally
weird you guys
was called the perfect read and it was
about
the beetle that they used to like crush
up to make that particular shade of red
dye
which was like super popular like in the
[ __ ] and it was like a huge [ __ ]
trade thing because that was everybody
wanted this particular dye
like for their thing because it was like
this big
you know it was like a really like um uh
you know a really expensive commodity
and the
the history of that like the history of
that the history of coffee beans like
all kind of stuff
because it ties in to like all these
other kind of um
you know kind of cultural things that
you don't think about i
love that kind of [ __ ] because everybody
can like learn about yeah the
you know wars and all that kind of [ __ ]
like you learn about that in school
i love like all the kind of little
details that kind of like
inform the larger history like or kind
of like cast light upon a larger history
like i said if you look upon if you read
a book about like the history of coffee
beans
if you look upon a history of like salt
or a history of like like i said the
whatever
the cockney albil beetle or whatever it
is that had that like that made that
particular red dye
if you look into that the history of
that it casts like this huge it's like a
tiny little thing but it casts like this
huge [ __ ] spotlight
on this particular like cultural aspect
of history that you never like thought
about i love that kind of that's like my
favorite genre of nonfiction and when
you're talking about
witches and witch paddocks i like to go
to [ __ ] salem a lot
all right when i was living in boston i
went to this i went to the salem witch
trial museum and did the tour
saw the [ __ ] where all those people
were buried and they're [ __ ] the
the old town of salem part of it is
still kind of there
the buildings i don't know if they're
recreations of the buildings or if
they're the actual buildings but
you can check for yourself big one of
the big misconceptions in the salem
witch trial these are all [ __ ]
lily white [ __ ] people from [ __ ]
england or something you know what i
mean
no not at all the only people in the
town of salem during that witch panic
that you would say were white people
okay like
like as white as me would have been like
the judge and his wife
and a couple of people that were just
pretty much new over here from england
the rest of them were all mixed
they were all mixed with native
americans native americans and there
were some africans in there too tituba i
think was she was african
tituba she was haitian i think yeah with
the haitians where the haitians came
from africa you know so
but it was most and it was because when
men showed up
when when when men showed up here from
europe
during this period women they're i don't
know what i promise
women didn't come with them for the most
part it was a [ __ ] deal yeah because
they're like [ __ ] that
like [ __ ] that would i have to be on a
boat for two months
nope so they they married native native
american women that were here
and you know the the whole salem thing
they had been here for a couple
generations they were already
all part indian and um
in that same period also there were
there were christian
indian nations which is something that
blows a lot of people's mind
but time [ __ ] 1800 had rolled around
a lot of the indians were christian
well as i said like there's nothing and
and as i said i understand that like if
you're in a history class in like high
school or whatever
they have a lot of ground to cover they
have to
simplify things to a degree but that's
why i always found it really instructive
to read histories that are based on like
a little thing because you get like all
this [ __ ]
that's why i found this particular case
even though
spoiler alert no one got hanged in this
particular case
but even that was very interesting to me
because it said something
about not only the pennsylvania colony
it said something about the quakers
yeah and how you know they had been
persecuted in england and
they came over here to escape
persecution because their beliefs and
blah blah
and it's like it was this whole thing
and it's like when you look into these
smaller cases
it really like casts late on like the
larger history like so i always
like find that kind of show really
fascinating the reason why you have
united states right now is about 60
caucasian as it is right now it's mostly
that was the repercussions of irish
immigration in the late 1800s
yeah a lot of irish came over just it
was just flooded with irish
and they just bred like cockroaches like
the [ __ ] irish do
sorry that's how i was created
but they were mixed in with the people
that were already here before my mom's
side of the family is average
yeah and so you know what i mean but
when you're talking about this
era of american history the people
looked a lot different
not as white as you think which is quite
surprising when you think about it
because that's not the way they're gonna
show it to you in a movie
i kind of feel like our history is more
like
australia's history yeah yeah where it's
like it's kind of like there's like an
aboriginal people that were there
then a bunch of white people came and
like and
of other white people there was like a
lot of interbreeding and then like so i
always feel like that's why i kind of
feel like australia is kind of like
the other united states in a way
you know what i mean yeah over here
there's a lot more people though
a lot more people true but i mean
culturally it seems more
situation was more similar it seems like
their their historical situation is a
lot more similar to ours than europe
yeah because we had like such a large
indigenous population
that were well that was there sometimes
displaced
sometimes integrated something what
happened to
the indian nations each one had their
own destiny
but for the most part even when the
1500s when the spaniards showed up in
new mexico a plague
[ __ ] went throughout the entire
americas and wiped out most of the north
american indians
that that was even squanto said that he
said his whole tribe was wiped out by a
plague
and he didn't understand what had
happened but that was that was a
spaghetti yeah [ __ ] bringing
germs from europe yeah then the
survivors of that plague was kind of
post-apocalyptic
and then waves of european immigrants
came in and bred in with most of those
until the late 1800s when you had
telegraphs and [ __ ] railroads
and that was the end of the indian
lifestyle and that's where you started
to hear all this stuff about putting
people into reservations and [ __ ] like
that
but that was only some of them during
that same period a lot of them were
joined in the u.s army i mean i'm not
saying
racism hasn't been a thing since forever
but i feel like the really hardcore
racism that people are talking about
nowadays that was kind of like an
industrial revolution thing
yeah it was a later advent before that
time racism wasn't that bad it was
usually just something that kind of came
and went
at certain times and in certain places
between certain people
because that's not a concept well prior
to that you were kind of like
like you said it was more like a method
of like a thing of practicality like
look there's no women you have better
white buddies so you have to marry
somebody it's like it doesn't matter if
she's a different way she's a person
she's a woman it's fine
like whatever when you go back into the
writing both the
white men and the white women are
choosing to live with indians and saying
that they were better looking
i yeah i feel like that was probably
yeah you had white men saying men and
indians are better looking than us
they're stronger and bigger
i mean i love that white men of that
time were able to
man up and admit that well we don't know
who we're talking about
they're like look at like we're so pasty
and
fat and like look at these i don't think
they're [ __ ]
i don't think they're running around in
the forest getting sun that's not what
they said though no i'm
not yeah that's not what they were
saying what
smith was saying is he said that native
americans had
better clothes britches and it was all
[ __ ] leather
well like i said they'd been living here
for thousands of years they had their
[ __ ]
together that they were stronger and
that muskets and [ __ ]
were useless against them that they used
things like [ __ ] war clubs
and they had bows that were silent and
that they were
raised in the field and so what they're
telling me is they're telling
the the white guys that were going there
were suburban in nature
at that time so you're not talking about
guys that were
farmers who were [ __ ] you know they
were largely city
they were skinny little dudes that's
what that's who that's who
like i said they were they were pasty
pasty skinny little [ __ ] suburban
urban type guys they weren't used to
like living outdoors
right right fishing and then all of a
sudden they go into this culture where
everything's wide open
you're mobile you know what i mean fresh
air
fresh clean water you're not worried
about a [ __ ] polluted water system in
wells or anything you live it off the
land
you don't have to worry about sexual
repression they were pretty evidently
the indians were pretty open about
things you know what i mean
well then it was more of a natural
camping type lifestyle well
like i said i'm not going to say like
because all the indian nations were
different but a lot of them were
as someone mentioned earlier matrilineal
or they were more like egalitarian
i guess it was more about how you how
much value you had as a person
right could you could you it wasn't so
much are you a dude are you a woman
if you could like do something to
contribute to the community it didn't
really matter
that's true although they though they
had strong gender roles though don't
look at it that way they you know i mean
they did have strong gender roles the
women worked they did [ __ ]
well yeah uh but the men did fight they
did hunt and you know what i mean they
they they were macho they were they it
was
by all accounts of the people that saw
it was a cool time
it was a very cool time and i can
imagine it has
having lived in the field myself is it's
an army it was an army type lifestyle
it produces a certain kind of person
between an army and a [ __ ] daryl
dixon
you know merle dixon type [ __ ] going on
your name
yeah yeah it's gonna produce a certain
kind of strong individual
sure you know that's what they're
talking about
you're not talking about some dude come
from suburbia or some [ __ ]
yeah well i mean that's the thing and
i'm not [ __ ] on people that have
just like
through no um you know you know
fault of their own [ __ ] leather pants
man this shit's sexy
they're talking about [ __ ] mad max
they're talking about wes from mad max
his ass coming out of the leather chaps
his ass coming out of the yeah
well you know you need like the breeze
like blowing through yeah
but um well that's the thing it's like
anybody
like i said through no fault of their
own have been raised in
you know cities where they don't really
go outside they're not in nature
they don't to hunt or fish they you know
they have all their things
done for them it's just kind of like if
you were brought up like that it's not
your fault i mean
your parents brought you up like that
but
when you come over here and we don't
have any of these huge
cities you know in you know central
south america they did because of the
maya the church
saying that the natives respected the
land and the white man didn't
uh no i'm gonna say you're wrong uh
during this period of the 15
15 16 1700s the white man also respected
the land what you're talking about you
better respect it because it will kick
you
talking about the end of that era during
the [ __ ] industrial revolution where
you had trains going everywhere and
they're [ __ ] shooting buffalo out of
a [ __ ] train window
for fun which leaving [ __ ] buffalo
yeah they didn't understand [ __ ]
ecology or they didn't value that kind
of [ __ ] obviously but
luckily that didn't last for very long
couple decades and people [ __ ]
stopped that [ __ ]
a lot of the [ __ ] bad [ __ ] that the
white man did during that period
was temporary you could only act a fool
for only so long before you go dude
we're [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
and stop shooting the [ __ ] buffalo
the buffalo pretty much went the buffalo
herds were [ __ ] wiped out
because they want to put cows there
instead yeah good job but they did not
[ __ ] drive the buffalo extinct
they're out there people you know what i
mean they're raising them for food
they're not extinct
well they're just but you can't have
buffalo herds
running around like they used to there's
too many houses there's [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh roads now you know just
[ __ ] changed um
you can't you can't live in the 18 16 17
1800s forever
not with the population we have yeah
there's too many of us there's too many
people
and you know if you want to take it on
yourself go kill all these people and go
ahead
but you know it's not gonna work
although i gotta say i mean the united
states is a very large country and there
are very large tracts of the united
states in which
not that many people live or know people
live yeah yeah
and a lot of people i think people don't
like realize how [ __ ]
massive and here's another thing there
used to be a time where prairie dogs
[ __ ]
had all of the southwest we're talking
about four or five states
they said witnesses said that all four
or five of those states was
one big prairie dog [ __ ] nest and
ferrets eating them and the prairie dogs
were probably like whoo man we got like
a
and they killed off all the most of the
prairie dogs because they kept breaking
cows feet
because their feet would go into the
into the holes in the holes so
it was a different ecology back then but
we should probably move on
we're getting [ __ ] bogged down in
cool stories about the past
he's telling me about this yeah sexy
[ __ ] and leather pants running
around [ __ ] elsa's going yeah i like
sexy [ __ ] with their pants
running around
right pants yeah tom's getting excited
about i'm not getting excited about that
[ __ ] i'm straight as [ __ ]
okay good okay
[Laughter]
he's trying to be all like defensive
about it shut up i'm straight
all right
[Laughter]
okay so one of the okay one of my
favorite things that i came across when
i was
researching witchcraft statutes from
this time period
was as i mentioned earlier because
witchcraft was largely believed to be
like
that was something that you didn't
witness firsthand and that was kind of
like
the big thing in courts then you had to
be like [ __ ] witness at first hand
so this was something that was
presumably done in secret so no one was
witnessing
it so they gave you a lot of leeway
in like what kind of evidence was
permitted
so at a witchcraft trial and this is a
[ __ ] quote from the [ __ ]
of what was like considered to be okay
evidence
and this would never fly nowadays but
i'm just telling you
so if a person that was brought before
the [ __ ]
like brought before a judge accused of
witchcraft or
similar they were allowed and this is a
quote
if his parents if they were wicked
were given to the same kind of fault i.e
if his parents had also been accused of
being weirdos or being like witches or
whatever
his nature if civil if hasty
witty and subtle a quarreler a pilferer
a bloody minded
so somebody that was kind of like maybe
would take your wallet
maybe was kind of like argumentative um
totally sufficient to be like brought up
on charges of whip witchcraft so
you know um his trade
for if a man liveth idly or vagrant if
you're a bomb
if you're unemployed again which
uh it's a good cause to arrest him upon
suspicion so they could arrest you
if you were just unemployed so
there's another thing um
his company with any of the offenders
obviously if any other people accused of
witchcraft were like buddies of his then
that was also suspicious
his course of life if a common ale house
haunter
if you hug out in bars which again i'd
be in
huge trouble riotous in diet
i think is what it's i mean it's the old
english that's like they didn't have
standardized spelling back then but i'm
pretty sure that that's what they were
saying
riotous in diet i'm not entirely sure
what that means like me
like you just ate a lot or i don't
really know what that means
um riotous in play or apparel so if you
dressed
weird or if you were super
exuberant about stuff i guess
then also you could be accused of
witchcraft and it was totally fine
um whether he be of evil fame or report
so like i said if other people thought
that he was
a witch or there was like rumors about
it then that was like totally legit
to act as evidence
against you if you were brought up on
some kind of charge
so um yeah so basically
since as i mentioned earlier since
christianity had kind of come to the
fore
um any kind of witchcraft any kind of
sorcery anything like that was
considered a capital offense
um in england at least and those were
the laws that kind of like transferred
over to the early
american colonies basically
um according to there was a history of
english law published by sir
frederick pollock and frederick william
maitland
um and in this particular history they
reported that 109
hangings of witches took place between
1644
and the death of oliver cromwell in 1958
but there i mean that was just the
deaths there were other like
witchcrafts that were witches that were
like prosecuted but like were not
killed they were either given a fine or
they were put in jail or they had
you know whatever something else um so
that doesn't really
tell the extent of it
so um and a lot of people it should be
mentioned too
that were put in jail for [ __ ]
witchcraft charges also died in jail
because the jails back then
not super fun not hygienic you know so
we're just saying that
so let's get back to margaret matson so
february 7th 19
uh 1683 rather than 1983
maybe okay 1683. now
i will say that okay so this is under
the julian calendar
um so this is like slightly different
date than nowadays
not sure that matters but i just thought
i'd mention it
so william penn and several of the first
people that came to pennsylvania and
like established it as like a colony or
whatever
this was only like a year and a half
after they had arrived
so william penn was a judge
at this trial and i'm gonna get a little
bit into william penn and the whole
quaker thing like a little bit later on
but let's talk about the trial
so they bring these two ladies before
the court margaret matson and the other
woman was named
yeshua hendrickson like i said they were
both swedish
now the charges against them um
[Music]
basically they're like okay they bring
them in and they're like
they said that their husbands should pay
50 pounds which back then that was a lot
of money that was a [ __ ] ton of money
that was thousands of dollars
this dude that i this uh dude's essay
that i read it was like like a five page
essay you can read it it's called the
fame of a witch
it's a pdf you can read it for free on
online
he's he calculated that it's about
equivalent
to a thousand days in jail
or about a year's worth of
hemp production like because hemp was
like considered
like money back then like money right so
he's saying like considering the time it
would have taken to grow it and like the
the amount it would like the amount of
land it would take to grow it he's like
that's about a year's worth of
so that's a lot of money so basically
they said to both the women's husbands
okay well you got to pay 50 pounds
for them to show up at court so
they did that so morning of february
27th
um william penn shows up there's
21 dudes that first show up that are
like you know for the jury pool
or whatever now
they basically they're like there's not
a lot of records from this time period
but like they're kind of spotty
but they don't have uh any record of
like what
the original like um prosecutor like
gave to the grand jury but they did have
like the
kind of jury selection they did select
12 guys
and they have the margaret matson comes
in and she basically pleads
not guilty so they're gonna try her
you know so i mean if she pleaded guilty
they would have like whatever
but she pleaded not guilty so they're
gonna go ahead to trial so they get 12
men
now i told you there was a bunch of cool
names in this
okay the interpreter that they aside
because
here's one thing that william penn did
and i i respect this [ __ ]
the two women were swedish they didn't
speak english or they spoke very little
english
so he did actually try to get them a
fair trial
in the sense that he got them an
interpreter that spoke english and
swedish and would speak for them
the interpreter's name was lassa
[ __ ] what so you know they probably just
meant rooster though
sounds like a porn name yeah right but
man don't take my phone they don't have
those kind of swear words don't take my
fun away
yeah so he is
so lost a [ __ ] i'm gonna say that as
many times as possible
was uh assigned as their interpreter
that's a cop loss of [ __ ]
it's a poor name yeah yeah if this dude
was alive nowadays
if we could go back in a time machine
that name and get him
and bring
[Music]
women love lots of cocky that's right so
lots of [ __ ] coming in
so much of it open your arms
right seriously i was i was researching
this case like earlier this week and i
read that name and i just busted out
like seriously this i can't make this
[ __ ] up
but yeah that was the dude's theme so
one thing that was interesting not only
did they get these ladies
an interpreter they also allowed
the women or at least margaret to
testify on her own behalf
which was nowadays that doesn't seem
like that big a deal
but back then that was kind of a big
deal
because women were not really allowed to
like testify
in court because ladies what the [ __ ] do
they know
no you weren't allowed but you gotta
remember this women weren't allowed to
testify in court
you gotta understand this is not an
american court
america does not exist at this time this
is well yeah this is prior
this is religious court yeah yeah
and even in england in england you
probably could no
in england uh women were actually not
allowed to take the stand in criminal
cases until the 19th century
okay so and like i said our laws a lot
of the colonial laws that like came from
england obviously because that's where a
lot of the uh
immigrants came from um but that still
was probably religious so this was kind
of ahead of its time
there was still prior religious law
because you're dealing with church of
england
see yeah you know what i mean
although you have to think too that this
whole trial took place in pennsylvania
and this was
uh founded by william penn who was a
quaker yeah who had fed
who had fled from england because of
persecution of the quakers because he
had parted from the anglican church
which i kind of weren't supposed to do
that he got in a lot of trouble telling
you that's all he got arrested a lot of
times
in england just because just because
they [ __ ] left church of england
doesn't mean that they were different
they weren't from our point of view yeah
from our point of view it wasn't they
were they fought over
different but from their point of view
it was a big deal
they fought over time to me it sounds
like that tiny little
interpretations of [ __ ] what was in
what was in the new testament that's
what they were fighting over
well yeah like i said but to them to
them it's a big deal to them
to them it's a big deal to us it seems
like why are we
why are you fighting about this you
don't understand religion i do
but i'm just saying that from somebody
that doesn't believe in that sort of
thing
it may seem like you guys are like when
you're dealing with when you're dealing
with societies that have
based their entire their entire uh
legal structure on a bible or religious
scripture
little things mean a lot in the in that
situation
well and the thing too is and
christianity ain't [ __ ]
when it comes to that kind of stuff if
you really want to see some wild [ __ ]
[ __ ]
study [ __ ] islamic history all the
different interpretations you know
because they got different different
interpretations of islam
and then an islamic law you know
so what you're talking about here
that ain't [ __ ] islam is even [ __ ]
more complicated well no but like i said
that's the thing it's like i feel like
that's kind of one of the
shittiest aspects of human behavior is
that
even people that in general have the
same belief systems like oh we're all
christians or whatever
um like i said i'm speaking to that as
an outsider
um you know we're all christians we're
all muslims whatever
but it's like so they they still want to
fight amongst themselves
so they will pick out the tiniest little
[ __ ]
thank you thank you dan christian
christian spent 1500 years killing each
other
of course fighting over that [ __ ] just
like and like i said william penn
who founded pennsylvania in case anyone
who was not from the us did not know
um was originally from the u.s i'll get
into his history a little bit later but
he's a quaker and his parents were
anglican
and his parents were very upset that he
had chosen to be a quaker
like i said to me it doesn't seem like a
huge
um you know schism or anything but to
them it was a massive massive deal
william penn was thrown in or was
arrested like many times in england
before he fled to the united states
so it was kind of like a big thing but
his quaker beliefs may have informed
why this witch trial went in a way
that the salem witch trials did not go
yeah that's what i'm saying
did you say thank you dan no no you
didn't
yes you say thank you i said thank you
okay you can get me another drink if you
want
well done my shit's empty okay all right
so as i said so they so the two ladies
had
a swedish interpreter and they were also
able to testify on their own behalf
which like i said was kind of a big deal
for the time because
usually that was not allowed um i should
say too that at this
time like pennsylvania it was like an
official state state but it was still
like
you know william had found it it was
like a colony or whatever a commonwealth
and william penn because he was a quaker
who were
notoriously um i guess notorious isn't a
great word but they were like pacifists
so he was very against the death penalty
so when this trial came to the fore and
he was adjudicating it
um basically the death penalty was off
the table so these women even if they
were found guilty
would not have been hanged because he
did not believe in it
and that was something that he had
established quite early on
like in this uh colony that the death
penalty was not allowed
except in cases of willful murder which
this was
not this was a witchcraft case like
somebody cursed my cows and they
wouldn't give milk anymore
or whatever so it wasn't she didn't kill
anybody or anything
so it wasn't to that extent
so basically like i said there's no
death penalty on the table
because that wasn't a thing that william
penn or his fellow quakers did
like i said they were pacifists they did
not do death penalty
so that was something that wasn't an
option
so basically what okay so what happens
is margaret matson and her co-defendant
let's call her that conor watson has
showed up he is in the house
oh my god finally the name william penn
is ringing a bell he was the founder of
pennsylvania that's why he's bringing
about like i said he escaped from
england because he was persecuted for
being a quaker
and is he the one that's on the quakers
box
i feel like that's william penn right i
have no idea he might be i think that
might be
a or at least like kind of like a what
they think
what they think you look like i thought
that was him
i may be wrong about that but i always
thought that the quakers i thought that
was william penn but
i don't know i could do it i can't tell
you i'm not into that
he's not into that i'm not into that no
he doesn't know i'm not into those
quaker oats
but i like them yeah but cookies
william penn made that [ __ ] he makes all
the oatmeal that we eat for breakfast
nowadays
but yeah so like i said the quakers were
pacifists so they were against the death
penalty
um although that would change later on
uh in 1718 the pennsylvania assembly
uh actually ended up extending their
list because like i said it wasn't just
will for murder that was
you know death penalty but that was the
only thing later on in 1718 the
pennsylvania assembly came forward and
they had a list of 14
capital offenses one of which included
witchcraft so had this
trial happened 14 years later these two
ladies probably would have been [ __ ]
so basically here was the evidence
the evidence at play i love this this
just is
this is emblematic to me of the [ __ ]
witchcraft trial [ __ ]
i mean we talked like i said we talked
about this in the salem witchcraft trial
but it's like some teenage girls being
like
you know i see the old lady over there
like she's pinching me like
spectrally or whatever and like
everybody bought it yeah
or at least they pretended to this is so
funny is those same girls decades later
were [ __ ] selling [ __ ]
that does not surprise me yeah they're
killing people based upon these [ __ ]
crazy ass sucking stories and then they
end up hookers
see these people well i feel like those
girls
yeah i mean i know they're dead now and
everything but like those girls like
do you not give a [ __ ] about your
actions and how they affect other people
do you not have any empathy or no
those girls were sociopaths yeah
sociopaths
yeah all they cared about was the
attention that they got
and they didn't care if they were they
obviously didn't care that they hurt
other people
there wasn't nothing else to do there
wasn't any social media or anything what
didn't you do
nobody else was doing that [ __ ] they
were [ __ ] crazy
other people weren't doing that [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] crazy life didn't offer
they were the worst life didn't offer
very much back then
right but that's like no excuse come on
don't be such a [ __ ] i thought that [ __ ]
was fun
that's what i mean they were sociopaths
don't be such a [ __ ]
yeah that's like your [ __ ] i don't i
don't understand why that's so hard for
people
but apparently it's hard for people just
stop being stop being a [ __ ]
just stop the town was boring let's kill
some people let's accuse my witches
right put on a big show and like
the and they got like tituba she was
like and they liked her yeah i thought
she got killed during that didn't she
didn't she get killed i think she did
i'd go back why would you do that i
think they killed tituba yeah
they didn't know they're oh i'm so bored
[ __ ] stupid
i'm just this friend that i have i'm
just gonna like have her killed that'd
be hilarious
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you it was
just like a a mass
psychosis i think a lot of it had to do
with they were in a pretty restrictive
environment
i get that like i feel like a little bit
of pity
okay it was kind of like it was kind of
like they were in prison
you know what i mean and uh they were
trying to lash out at the people that
were
keeping them under wraps and keeping
that for what did they lash out at their
[ __ ] parents then
accuse your [ __ ] parents that's who's
like [ __ ] or accuse people in power
why didn't they do that i don't even
think that way
don't [ __ ] on people like below you they
were kids quote unquote they were kids
that's [ __ ] up if you're going to go
after somebody in that fashion go after
somebody that's actually like
maybe partly responsible for your misery
don't go after like some people that
are like well they're teenagers like you
and that like don't have any power over
your [ __ ] life
they're teenage girls [ __ ] they're
teenage girls they don't know any better
they're teenagers
back in the 1600s it's kind of like the
whole thing and i know it's kids and
everything it's the bullying mentality
it's like a lot of people
like that are bullies like when they're
kids they're bullies because
they get [ __ ] on at home and so they
feel like well my parents are
beating me up or emotionally abusing me
or whatever so i'm gonna go and pick on
someone weaker than me
to make myself feel better because i
can't lash out against them because
they're bigger than i am
they weren't getting beat up at home
though that's not the same no i'm just
saying in general that's kind of like
the bullying mentality with the salem
trials the
what the problem was is that the town
was very religious and very strict
which would have for teenage girls been
a [ __ ] drag
so they felt like they were under the
raps of all these people
then they started [ __ ] around and
getting them to [ __ ] do all these
weird ritual
trial stuffs based upon just crazy [ __ ]
that they were saying well and they were
getting attention they were getting it
everyone was taking them seriously
which was probably a new thing and then
they see the adults falling for this
[ __ ] and they're going these people are
[ __ ] stupid
so then they start oh yeah then they
start losing faith
in what they were taught they were like
these they're just like man i'm just
gonna say
whatever they'll believe they'll believe
anything so
that was that's what you're dealing with
there and then eventually when they when
they got old enough to get out of that
town what do they do
they go become hookers
you know because i think they have like
three of them i think this is why you
should never give teenagers power
it was just because they were like ah
they're just a bunch of religious
fanatics you know
[ __ ] them that you know that
that particular lifestyle that they were
living in that colony was going the way
of the dodo bird anyway when that was
going on
it was out it was out of style then yeah
all right and they didn't like it
and that was how they acted like i get
that like i said i do feel some sympathy
in that regard i can see how
but the people that they got killed i
don't think i don't think they
actually thought they would do it but
then they did it
and then it started being on itself
because you don't if you really believe
that like people that are
in authority are that stupid then it's
probably better to keep your mouth shut
because
if you like say some [ __ ] and they
believe it and like people get killed
that's on you here's a good analogy
here's a good analogy
in communist russia in soviet russia
if you did not believe in communism if
you
hated communism all right where you
wanted to go in life was to join the kgb
all right in the kgb you had the power
to be free
from you know what i mean [ __ ] you
had the power to be free from [ __ ]
communism in a certain way
because you were in a position of
authority so
when you go back and look at what
communist or what kgb
agents did mostly is kgb
mostly killed commies they [ __ ] hated
commies
and they killed commies using comedy
mentality and commie rules
that's kind of what you're talking about
these witch trials you know what i mean
yeah they didn't like this this religion
so they used the rules of that
religion to punish the people that
believed in it
yeah and there's a lot of [ __ ] ex-kgb
agents that was said that they spent
their time basically
killing commies using the rules of
commies that they thought that [ __ ] was
[ __ ]
so it was like that well
like i said it's very human too also
it's very human too if you feel
powerless to [ __ ] on people who are
less powerful than you because you can't
get back at the people that are actually
oppressing you
exactly so you have to like [ __ ] on
people who can't get back at you right
and that's what
that's a very human thing it's sad but
it's yeah and that's what made the kgb
so hated and so dangerous
they were people that didn't believe in
any of this [ __ ]
soviet communist [ __ ] and they sat
around then they ran around
applying that standard to everyone else
because they hated them like oh you're a
[ __ ] county you know what i mean
and they'd walk them to the gallows and
[ __ ] hang them for
doing anti-communist activity that they
knew was [ __ ]
but they're like oh well [ __ ] them well
like you said that's that's kind of like
that i think that's why the salem witch
trials get brought up a lot because you
can
see a lot of [ __ ] that is still like
relevant in
human psychology is that these teenage
girls
were obviously i mean they were
privileged in a sense
because they weren't poor necessarily
they were kind of like higher up in the
community or whatever
but because they were girls because they
were teenagers they didn't have a lot of
power
and i feel like they were trying to
assert their power
in a really twisted way like the but the
only way that they knew how
um but they couldn't get back at the
actual authorities that were
actually oppressing them so they decided
to [ __ ] on people who were
below them quote unquote from a social
standpoint like somebody that was a
slave or somebody that was old somebody
that was mentally ill
somebody so they were just kind of like
punching down
is what they were doing well they start
off that's all they could do
they start off punching down because
they know they can get away with it
sure but they're punching down because
they know that those people believe in
this [ __ ]
well the longer they get away with that
like you said the second they started
punching up
then all of a sudden then it stopped but
i think the original and i think what
they do
is is that they want to punch up but
they can't well that's what they don't
have the confidence
that's what i was just saying so they
punch down first they're just going
after any of these [ __ ]
quaker christians they don't like them
so they're gonna go for the [ __ ] ones
at the bottom first
and once they get away with that they're
going to move it up they moved it up to
the
governor's wife because like i said who
was there oh no
first person that they accused tituba
yeah because she was mixed race
and she was a slave that's easy so they
yeah she's an easy target yeah
and what they and and it wasn't just her
it's not her color what it was
is that they she was always suspect of
of having something to do with voodoo
sure
so voodoo would be interpreted as
witchcraft
so like i said she was an easy target
right
so they knew that they would be safe
going after no one's gonna say anything
to them
yeah because they could go to you know
everyone's going to believe them over
her
obviously which is it's kind of weird
you know growing up in brazil you know i
[ __ ] used to see my kumba i went to a
makuma [ __ ]
priest you know [ __ ] my friend who
was a taxi cab driver
took me to makuma church it was [ __ ]
awesome they're [ __ ]
doing the rituals they sacrifice a
chicken on the way in because
priests could eat the chicken yeah you
know chickens they eat it
chicken chicken they eat it and then a
lot of singing and dancing and talking
to the spirits and [ __ ] it was like
something right over a james bond movie
and i was seeing this stuff
in the you know in like 86 87 i [ __ ]
loved it
cute girls [ __ ] dressed up in their
white dresses puffing on cigars
and it was it was not it was neat real
neat it's funny how well
it was church like any other church
that's what i mean i feel like
particularly in the mid to late 80s i
feel like there were a lot of movies
that came out that were kind of like
trying to demonize
but it's not the way it was and honestly
a lot of it is
uh stems from catholicism yeah it's
because it's an african folk religion
sure but it's like it's it's kind of
like mingled in with catholicism it's
just
it's just like any other same [ __ ] it's
not scary they had their own
saints and everything and it's just the
people's
version of catholicism sure it's just
people's catholics so weird
and um it was about singing and dancing
and
and having a good time and you give some
money to the [ __ ] priest
and say put a prayer in for this and
this and that and then he'd have the
girls [ __ ] that's like i said just
like any other just like
any other [ __ ] third not and uh you
know that was back you know
[ __ ] i was living in brazil and
[ __ ] i thought it was like something
out of a damn
cross between a james bond movie and a
damn duran duran video
had a good time it was one of the better
churches that i've been to
so there wasn't anything sinister about
it see that's what it is so i was going
to say it's kind of
it's kind of sad that they focus in on
somebody who
believes in voodoo there's no difference
between voodoo macumba and condembley
and
santeria it's all the same thing and
it's a
it's africanized catholicism is all it
is well all they're doing
is the same same thing christians do
they do their same thing
they're just like look they're giving an
offering yeah that
like look please save my mom from cancer
please they're asking for yeah it's just
like
that's just like baptists and [ __ ]
drinking snake poison and it's that same
[ __ ] concept
it's the same concept the only
difference is is that
instead of an ordained minister
or or an ordained catholic priest that's
doing it
it's a people's priest and it's
different
saints it's local saints right but
the stories behind the local saints
there's nothing sinister about them
yeah like i said there's there's nothing
now mexico has one you know santa muerte
which is you know well i'm sure yeah
it's similar but the but the cartel
members like
like the the saint death or or the
the grim reaper man they did a
paranormal witness yeah the grim reaper
which it's
kind of like it's kind of like devil
worship it's devil
worship but that's
strong in it's gonna sound crazy but you
know i got khan in there with me
in mesoamerican religions you did give
offerings to devils
and demons because you had to pay them
off
you know most of the mesoamerican
religions
you know um they had good gods and evil
gods
and you weren't and all of them had to
be appeased all of them had to be
appeased
so that's what they're talking about
there uh
so you [ __ ] hardcore christian might
say that's devil worship
well more like devil bribery yeah
they're just like hey don't [ __ ] with me
yeah don't [ __ ] with me [ __ ] with this
other dude yeah go
go [ __ ] with that guy leave me alone
mostly
[Laughter]
like i said any religion that has to do
with
hey i'm gonna give you some [ __ ] to like
leave me alone or don't
[ __ ] with my [ __ ] yeah it's totally
under like i don't believe in it but
it's totally understandable
yeah so it's like anything like it
doesn't seem evil to me or nothing it
just seems like
you're you're just like playing like you
know just
to be safe okay we gotta put out a
warning we're in intoxication level two
right now
he told me that i should do we were
talking about this last night
that he told me i should make a graphic
that was like
a traffic light yeah and so like when
it's green
we're still kind of sober yeah when it's
yellow or when it's yellow
we're still wait it could go either way
but then when we're red we're like so
[ __ ] up that we're not gonna remember
what we're saying
yellow right now i'm on yellow right now
yeah i think i'm still at yellow at this
point yeah
i've had two drinks but i'm all right
now khan says
uh malverdi also i don't know who
malverde is
evil green who's evil green malverde
must be another um something like santa
muerte
i don't know who that is see i gotta go
here's the deal people
i gotta go i gotta go [ __ ] to tijuana
and go hang out with [ __ ] khan
and uh i gotta go i gotta go see mexico
myself
ken says we should do five stages like
defcon yeah
oh that's actually i like that idea
actually that's a better idea than a
traffic light
khan works at a nice he works at a nice
hotel he's in the hotel industry maybe
uh
he could hook me up with a hotel or
something but i want to get down there
and try some of those mexican tacos that
i saw on television the way they were
doing some [ __ ]
and i want to i want to see i want to
see those pyramids
taco chronicles that netflix series made
me so hungry
yeah that's where i learned how to cook
i wanted to eat all of the things that's
going to be in the recipe
that's the be in the cookbook i got the
cup i wanted to eat all of the things on
that show
but uh every single thing man now seeing
that [ __ ] makes you want to go to
[ __ ] mexico
that's gonna be [ __ ] awesome i would
like i would like that actually
yeah let's go to mexico i've never been
in mexico
but you know i've been to europe and i'm
mexico
so okay so margaret matthew
hernandez says that malverde was a
[ __ ] bandit and he's a saint to the
cartels okay
all right bad green yeah
ilsa is saying she's eating tacos el
pastor right now
on a food truck man that's a hard one we
can't get el pastor because that's like
a rotisserie
uh uh that's almost a year that's what
they did a whole episode that's like a
greek
taco a greek mexican greek taco
yeah that was the one that was on like
the rotisserie thing yeah it's like on a
rotisserie
it was kind of like a gido yeah man that
looked good
it did well like i said we watched that
[ __ ] [ __ ] we watched that whole
series right taco chronicles it's on
netflix in the us i don't know about
other places
but khan's chiming in saying that
[ __ ] malverde was abandoned he was
like
everything on there okay all right
yeah you gotta go do a taco tour mal
verde is the mexican robin hood that's
it he made tacos you made tacos for
lunch today yeah i made tacos for lunch
today
yeah with pork yeah pork pork parroted
the pork tenderloin and that
poor tenderloin marinated a little bit
of a little bit of olive
oil some [ __ ] garlic some salt
cumin and a little bit of cocoa powder
man that [ __ ] came out [ __ ] good
oh and i also threw a little bit of the
jalapeno juice from the [ __ ]
jar the jalapeno jar i put a little bit
of jalapeno juice in oh dear
yeah and you threw one little jalapeno
slice on yeah
but i marinated that meat like that for
several hours had it sliced thin
and then yeah it was good i didn't make
those tortillas though i got my sack i
got so much miseka
you got [ __ ] khan man his name is
jair jair he [ __ ] turned me on to
making my own
corn tortillas with that masekah man it
they are much better it's so much better
the store-bought ones are
okay fast you can for the store-bought
stuff it's
faster but the handmade ones yeah
i'm gonna try some of that blue masaka
oh yeah
that's enough yeah we don't have it
around here but i'll have to order it
you can get it on amazon yeah get it on
amazon yeah
all right so it's good yeah it is
um all right so i'm going back to henry
dry street remember that guy he was the
first guy
that accused margaret matthew like
[ __ ] his cows up because they weren't
given milk or whatnot
so weirdly and i don't really know how
this was allowed
but he was like the first dude that
accused but he was also in the grand
jury
so i guess that was all right i don't
know seems like a conflict of interest
but whatever so he comes forward and he
says look man
i've been hearing for like 20 years that
this [ __ ]
is a witch right and as i
mentioned earlier this was kind of
enough to
make people suspect you that oh i've
just heard for a long time a lot of
people told me that [ __ ]
so he said that so he's like oh like a
bunch of my cows i got bewitched or
whatever
um he also said that this other dude's
mom told him that
her cow had also been bewitched now the
funniest thing about this though and
this is from the [ __ ]
trial transcripts so um
take this as you will because this is a
quote
so the other woman so the other dude's
mom says
that oh my cow is bewitched but quote
afterwards
said it was a mistake and that her cow
should do well again for it was not her
cow but another persons that should die
so i'm not really sure if that means
that margaret was saying
well i meant to curse that bitch's cow
but accidentally
i cursed your cow that's kind of how i
read it
but i don't really know if that's
i don't know if that's what it was but
that's kind of like how i felt like
well i was cursing cows and i was doing
the [ __ ] indiscriminately
like you do and i just your cow just got
like caught in the crossfire
i was meaning to curse your neighbor's
cow but i just got your cow
sorry about that i kind of feel like
that was all right yeah it's a malverde
of course in in portuguese mao
means evil verde is green right evil
green they're saying it's bad green yeah
well mal
is melvin evil in french as well yeah
and then can i hear you good
is the best one and then people are
saying yeah we're segueing into food now
i know it should happen
and he says there's green and red maseka
i saw the blue one and for for some
reason the blue one [ __ ] spoke to me
i
i was thinking man that blue looks
pretty good but i want to try them
all but you know let me see what is it
which one i have i have a whole bunch of
that [ __ ] stored right here
i got right now i got like
six of these i got like six of these man
i don't know if it's yellow or white
i think this is the yellow one
jair is that the yellow one or the white
one
i got like [ __ ] six or seven of these
things man
i ordered like a whole case of that [ __ ]
for the apocalypse
for the [ __ ] trump apocalypse
what are you doing he's saying that
that's the white yet okay that's the
white one
i showed on the maseka that i have i got
like six of those
six or seven of them i was in the
bathroom and i heard like the closet
door slamming
that's the way that's going on all right
well that's the one that's the most
common here
in in the united states is that white
one
in my area but yeah i'd like to i don't
want to try them all that minute shit's
so [ __ ] good i got the press
it's [ __ ] cast iron press them out
put the two pieces of plastic in there
for you europeans
who think you know mexican food you do
not understand
the beauty of the [ __ ] corn tortilla
when it's handmade
you put that in a second put water in
that masaka and it soaks it up
it's a huge difference huge difference
then you make them
a ball of that [ __ ] you make little
balls about the size of a ping-pong ball
and you put it in a press now you want
to use a sheet of plastic on either side
of it so it doesn't stick to the press
you squeeze it down and it comes out as
a tortilla you throw that on a hot no
stick pan
cook them both sides and then you can
store them like that
and the flavor on those tortillas is so
much better than a
pre-made store-bought tortilla you just
you can't understand it
it's like a [ __ ] beautiful cornbread
flavor
it goes so well with any kind of pork uh
any kind of [ __ ] sauce on top of it
and gravies
and look at there's a is it what was
that youtube no no that was uh
the taco chronicles was that on netflix
yeah on net on netflix there's a whole
series called taco crop yeah it's two
seasons i think two seasons
and they'll show you this all these
little
taqueras you know which are little
[ __ ] taco places
and street vendors of tacos and all the
different ways that they do tacos
it's a whole cuisine cuisine into itself
man it's [ __ ]
beautiful what they're doing that in
mexico
it's kind of like in europe they will
never
understand a real american hamburger
what we're doing here with a hamburger
you're never going to find that in
[ __ ] europe okay
it's the same thing with the taco you're
not going to find
in europe or in the united states what
they're doing with a taco down in mexico
it's just so much better so i started to
do it a lot what they're doing
that's how i do it now it's so much
better
well there's a whole it's just like
anything else once you look into it it's
a lot more like
um you know there's a lot more like
[ __ ] fast it's a lot more diverse
than you would think
there's so many different ways to do it
you could do it with a copy you got it
with two taco shells on it
you got a flower you got a gorgeous
style there's all different kinds of
ways to do it
and then the meat that's inside what
kind of vegetables you gotta understand
some mexicans do not like vegetables
but if you're gonna they don't like
vegetables why would the [ __ ] would you
want vegetables you got
something like this one got meat on that
meat and gravy
something you want white cheese on it
they got a lot of mexican white cheeses
you can use mozzarella
don't use that [ __ ] cheddar cheese
that's an american thing
cheddar is a british cheese it does not
belong on a [ __ ] taco i mean cheddar
is good but
it's it's not the same other
applications now that i went over to
that
to that white cheeses here it's really
easy to get mozzarella
mozzarella on a taco is [ __ ] 10 times
better
than that so-called mexican blend cheese
which is cheddar and [ __ ] monterey
jackets
white cheese is so much better on it i
made one of them with
philip i made a taco for her one time
that had philadelphia cream cheese
which should not be on a taco but it is
white cheese and
it was [ __ ] awesome well cream cheese
is just cream cheese
yeah yeah you can put cream cheese on
pretty much anything and i'll eat it
right you know what i'm saying look
we're segueing off into food let's go
ahead and get back to witchcraft no i'm
just saying well i was going to say
i was going to say one more thing go
ahead well i forgot what it was because
it was like a long time ago but
[Laughter]
yeah which one i need that's the white
one
um okay go ahead good i'm ready
you sure somebody said baby yoda moved
yeah i saw that earlier did he really
what they say is he throwing up back
there eating eggs or something yeah
yeah he may be which reminds me
you should probably check on pookie okay
i'll check in a minute
she's outside right yeah she's outside i
mean it's only eight o'clock she can be
on the porch but you know what i mean
so okay so like i said the first dude
that gave like witness testimony in this
[ __ ] trial
was basically like um
yeah she bewitched my cows so that they
wouldn't give milk but also
like this other chick like this other
chicks
mom said yeah she'd be wish my cows too
but maybe she meant to bewitch somebody
else's cow i don't know i'm not real
clear on that
so they brought this other witness up
and he said that uh quote-unquote
anthony's wife which was actually
matson's
daughter who was married to some other
dudes this is like
her daughter and her daughter-in-law um
so she had sold her cattle i guess
and this dude and this is turtle here
say you guys this would like not fly
nowadays
but the daughter apparently
said that i like
sold my cattle because
my mom bewitched them
um and the quote was
having taken the witchcraft of hendricks
cattle which was
you know one of the dudes that like uh
you know testified or whatever somebody
in this situation
and put it on their oxen which i don't
really
i don't i don't know i don't get that
i don't get that but whatever
so the i don't know
so the quote was she might keep but no
other cattle
so what are they saying here like
i curse the cattle because i couldn't
curse the oxen
or i wanted to curse the oxen and like
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't get it i don't get
witchcraft i don't get old english i'm
just saying
i don't get it but there was a whole
thing about that
he also said the same person he said
that margaret matson's
daughter had told him and like i said
this is totally here say this is not
full
this would not fly in a modern court um
he said that margaret's
daughter totally told me and this is a
quote
there was a great light but just before
an old woman with a knife in her hand
appeared at the bed's feet so basically
he woke up
he saw some old woman standing at the
foot of his bed
with a knife and
said cried out quote unquote cried and
cried
cried out and desired something somebody
simcock i don't know who that is
to take away his calves or else she
would send them to hell
so apparently this old woman allegedly
shows up
at this dude's bedstead
holding a knife saying
take your calves away
or something or i will
i don't know i don't know how witchcraft
works so there was that whole thing
the third witness was this woman named
anakie kulin now she said
that sh that her husband
they had a calf on their farm that died
right
and they thought that the calf did you
oh well hey poo the door opened and i
thought it was tom but it was actually
pookie
she must have come back inside which do
poke can you do witchcraft
so yeah
um hey
yeah what's up you all right
nothing i'm just like what are you doing
all right so
all right so where was i i don't know
pookie came
in and like i was kind of looking like
that did you let her back in
yeah let her in and then went to
restroom all right so
the third witness this woman named
anakie kulin
she comes in she says we had a calf and
it died
and they thought that witchcraft had
killed it
although maybe unspecific like they
didn't know who like who caused the
witchcraft allegedly
so they're like well um okay so what
we'll do
is we'll take the heart of the calf
and boil it which was something that you
did i guess
when one of your cows died of witchcraft
i don't know
like i said i'm i wasn't born back then
and i'll like know what their
deal was so
they boiled it and then he said
and as i said this is like it's it's
funny to
kind of like look into these witch
trials from a long time ago because
you could totally get on the stand and
be like dude
this dude said that this other dude said
this [ __ ]
and like everyone would believe you
which that's crazy
you you can't do that nowadays but so
this dude said that
the woman that margaret madsen had come
in
at that point when they were boiling the
heart of this calf
that they thought had died from
witchcraft
and told them that oh you should have
boiled the bones
and told them like a bunch of other [ __ ]
that they should have done
if they thought that the calf died of
witchcraft so
that was like another kind of hearsay
thing where it's like oh this woman just
like turned up at our door and said hey
what are you doing you're like
if you thought that was witchcraft
that's not how you go about it
so that was like yeah that was another
thing
so margaret madsen
actually got to take the stand which
like i said was unusual for this
time period because usually women were
not uh given this much latitude
we're not given any uh credence in
courts
so she comes and gives her own testimony
she didn't have an attorney or anything
like that
she basically said look that dry street
dude whatever he said
that was [ __ ] that's what she said
i'm paraphrasing
um and also that if this
other person that said oh their mom said
this and that they're like well if that
actual person had come forward
and gave me some like charges yeah i
would have said something to that but
otherwise
[ __ ] off again i'm paraphrasing
um and she's like so basically she kind
of like came on the stand and like look
if any of you people
like that you're talking about like
actually came here
and accused me directly
then i would talk to them but since
they're not here then
point that's kind of what she did which
good for her so basically
the whole thing about the calf's heart
she's like yeah i didn't do that like i
don't know what you're talking about i
don't know anything about that
now another thing that happened though
was that william penn who as i said was
adjudicating this whole [ __ ] trial
very famously
he supposedly asked her a couple
questions
and were like did you and
this was kind of a common thing in witch
trials at the time they would ask you
did you do this
did you ride on a broomstick yada yada
so william penn or whoever was like
asking the questions at trial
like supposedly said did you ride a
broomstick at any point is it like
whatever
and margaret supposedly
said yeah i totally did that i don't
know if she was like trying to be like
sarcastic which if she was i wouldn't
blame her
maybe she was trying to be a smart ass i
don't know yeah did you write a broom
ticket yeah i totally did
whatever now another thing that was
funny about this was that william penn
was kind of like well writing on a
broomstick
in itself is not illegal
so the fact that she admitted to that
isn't really kind of like so i feel like
william penn
even though and i want to get into this
a little bit because
as a quaker they did have
a like it was enough of a rift
like in the whole like from the anglican
church or whatever for
everyone to be all upset about it um he
did still believe in witches he did
still believe that witches were real
he did still believe that satan was real
he wasn't like some big enlightened
i mean he was maybe slightly more
enlightened but he wasn't like
so enlightened that he was like yeah all
that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
but he was smart enough to be like
he understood that these
two women who were accused because like
i said it wasn't just margaret matson it
was another chick as well that
there wasn't really enough evidence to
kill them you know what i'm saying so
the fact that he was
willing to come forward and be like
not say outright i think this [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
but that he basically came forward he
did like the best thing that he could do
what ended up happening in this
particular case which i think is very
interesting
is that the verdict
in this case which even there's no like
super record of it or anything like that
but the what ended up happening
was that the jury's finding
was that they were found guilty of
having the common fame
of a witch so guilty of like other
people
saying that they were witches basically
but not guilty in manner and form
as she stands indicted so saying that
you are guilty of like being
thought to be a witch but not guilty
of cursing people's
cattle which is what she was initially
brought
which was actually a really good
diplomatic
way of making everyone happy i guess
because william penn was kind of like he
did believe in witches i'm not saying he
didn't
but the fact that he didn't think there
was enough evidence to convict these
women
to the fact that you know to the extent
that they would be
executed so he's basically like well
you people think they're witches okay
i'm giving you that
but given that
yeah sure they're guilty of that but i'm
not gonna say
that they're guilty of killing your cows
because then that maybe necessarily
would lead to them being executed or
being jailed and they didn't he didn't
want to go that far
which in a way was
like i said he wasn't like dropping his
nuts and saying like you guys are
[ __ ] and like wishes don't exist
which
would have been you know um pretty out
there for that time
but he was saying that like look i don't
think you have enough evidence to
convict these women but i also don't
want you guys getting mad at me
so i'm basically saying okay fine
they're witches
but i don't think you've sufficiently
proved
the specific charges against them which
i think was a really good diplomatic
solution
in this uh you know particular
situation i'm just saying that he he
kind of resolved in a really good
uh way that sadly would not
carry through to the salem witch trials
nine years later in which
we all know how that turned out you know
what i'm saying
so where pretty much anything was what
are you you're all right
no i'm just responding this with
somebody with somebody said there what'd
somebody say
he also said that she lives in brooklyn
right she did
and um she really forget that food
trucks aren't everywhere and she wishes
there was a [ __ ] taco
truck there but i'm saying we do have
some but not a lot
we used to have here in orlando all
kinds of great food trucks but they
changed the laws because
downtown orlando didn't want to compete
with those food trucks well the
restaurants didn't want to compete yeah
one of the food trucks was the cupcake
truck that [ __ ] that was kind of
probably the most famous one the [ __ ]
cupcake truck they had a facebook i was
on their facebook page and everything
yeah now we're getting back to food but
[ __ ] that's all right
this show's about food and all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] all right now
ilsa if you haven't seen taco chronicles
on on
on [ __ ] netflix check that out
because when you see
how mexicans make tacos it's so much
better than
a california-based taco you see we got
we got chicano tacos here
that's that's what mexican-americans in
in
in in california made that's kind of
what i grew up with
that's kind of generic you know a lot of
amer got a lot of american
um ingredients like cheddar cheese and
[ __ ] you know what i mean
the way they do the a lot of times
they're good with them they're good but
it's not
it's not the same yeah i was watching
the way
mexicans do it on their trucks and in
taqueros
you know which is like little kind of
like a luncha nachi it's like a [ __ ]
and what's what we call it in brazil
lunch or nachi which is like a [ __ ]
diner
but it's a diner that's taco based
diner all right and the way they do it
they're on a big old griddle
it's so much better man they got gravy
on the damn taco
so cookies you have gravy on cooking a
taco and
or like a stew it's like a stew inside a
taco
or they take the [ __ ] taco shell the
corn tortilla
and they'll throw a little bit of damn
oil that came out of the the [ __ ] uh
the slow cooker that had the damn pork
in it you know what i mean
and it's red you know the red oils and
just you just see how they do it
and and the components and then instead
of lettuce and [ __ ] lettuce
they'll throw what we would call
coleslaw mix on it which is the shredded
cabbage which makes perfect sense well
it's more nutritious
well coleslaw mix it's cheap and it
lasts forever in the damn refrigerator
it doesn't wilt the way
if you shred lettuce it's wilted the
next day
but if you have a bag of [ __ ]
shredded cabbage that'll last two weeks
so of course you want to use the cabbage
and it still gives you that same crunch
and then you know the pico de gallo or
the salsa that they're making depends
and then the guacamole how they do it
and then how how mexicans make waka
sauce
which is uh avocado sauce the way they
do it is is different you know they
blend it
um i kind of like california waka sauce
i think the way it looks
i'll have to try it um the california
guacamole is thicker it's more like
mashed
water which is you know what do you call
it what zawaka
avocado with
uh diced tomatoes and onions in it with
some um
seasoning and i like that one because
it's it's a little more
solid it's harder like kind of like a
sour cream which mexicans don't put sour
cream on taco that's
that's a gringo thing the mexican wacko
sauce is [ __ ]
a little more watery it's blended
it didn't look as good i'd like to try
it i'm gonna try it i'm gonna give
keep an open mind but the california
waka sauce looks a bit better
maybe hernandez will [ __ ] and maybe
her man does
because hernandez is in california he
knows exactly what i'm talking about
i grew up in carson you know part of my
part of my time in carson so i know
chicano food
you know it's [ __ ] good really good
wet burritos and [ __ ] [ __ ] i
grew up back in this damn 70s back
before people even knew what cholesterol
was back when you
back when you went to a mexican [ __ ]
chicano restaurant and they gave you a
damn
mug of pork fat yeah drink some pork fat
we didn't worry about that [ __ ] man what
are you talking about
taquitos and [ __ ] and nachos and all
that kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
little mexican candies that look like a
little umbrella and [ __ ]
hernandez louis knows what i'm talking
about
[Laughter]
but i haven't had good menudo i'm just
going to say i haven't had good menudo
my boy in the army [ __ ] shafina he
was another cali [ __ ] he's he's not
he's from california too
he was [ __ ] chicago and he only gave
me the shitty menudo it came out of a
can
we were up in korea he's nobody
[Music]
yeah he's cooking that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] barracks and it smelled pretty
good it says let me have some of that
and i taste this
because yeah it's not as good as my mom
makes but this is you know
nothing out of a can is as good as all
he can soup and [ __ ] but
other than that yeah but i i'd [ __ ]
like to have some real menudo
and i'm not a tripe kind of guy not you
know what i mean
but i'd give it a chance you know
because i trust
also not a trait from what i've seen so
far
i kind of trust the mexican palette you
know they know what tastes good i just
like to try some good
some good menudo it's stinky
stinky that's just how it is that's how
it is you know
that doesn't mean it can't be any worse
than haggis
trip okay and i'm not eating that yeah
i'm not eating blood sausage either yeah
right yeah
it does smell good i will admit that
like because like i said when i was over
there
some people in my ex's extended family
yeah
were eating that chick because they
would eat like eggs and blood sausage
for like breakfast they're talking about
getting meaty manure and baked beans and
stuff and i was like well it smells good
but
i don't know all right [ __ ] [ __ ]
jair and [ __ ] uh a shy ears [ __ ]
fight with louie saying well i'm not
really fighting
but jay here says the chicano tacos man
are made by fake mexicans that don't
count
damn well no taco rivalry
they addressed that a little bit on taco
chronicles
i feel like because there were some
chicano
like people that had like open
restaurants in california saying that
were like first or second generation
and i do feel like there was kind of
some [ __ ]
between them and like actual mexicans
they were like man you're not doing it
right you're like trying to cater to
like american palettes and
that's [ __ ] so i do kind of feel
like there's a little bit of rivalry
yeah but it all looks i would eat all of
it louie telling me tom you should try
some mexican
babadooka i don't know what babar okay
yes
what is barbacoa bob rocco what is bob
raccola
i don't know sophie says jenny you ever
eat spaghetti out of a can i did
yes um well that was one thing that was
like really weird to me is that
the brits will eat toast
and essentially
yeah and i i was like this is not
like spaghettios it's not exactly the
same thing but i was like spaghetti is
this not breakfast food
i mean at least in the u.s i mean i i
know we can't judge
like we eat donuts and like [ __ ]
dessert for breakfast so okay i get that
jair is saying i'm not eating
spaghettios for breakfast
jair is saying for a real taco you got
to be back
in the motherland and of course he's
talking about the [ __ ] motherland
which is right there
next to the honking it's like the well
it's not next to the honky village it's
not quite this
is the scene it's a couple of oceans
it's a couple of ways
there's the wet back motherland and the
hockey motherland right not the indian
ocean what the [ __ ] am i talking about
the gulf of mexico
it's the atlantic ocean indian ocean i
don't know what the oracle's going i was
wondering if tom would be on a tangent
when he came back you know what kind of
they were [ __ ] with me tom's always
at a tangent western between cal mex and
text me next
tex-mex tex tex-mex is very similar
tex-mex is
like a lot more chilly [ __ ] going on
okay but
sin it's real nowadays it'll be very
similar
barbecue might might be slightly
included a little bit in tex-mex
i feel like maybe yeah there's like some
barbecue [ __ ] going on like that because
barbecue is like a huge thing scott and
said he's currently
ordering some mexican food right now so
i'm talking
yeah well any food sounds good right now
i gotta tell you
they're talking about black beans spam
taco
yeah spam powered tacos
are you done can i just yeah yeah yeah
go ahead go go go go go fill it finish
okay so
so i had a lot more but i'm like not
gonna because we're already
almost we're like yeah but
so i'm just gonna say this case did not
end up the way
that you might think the way the salem
trials ended up with like everybody
getting killed which
you know that's obviously not a good
turnout for anybody
this case basically what william penn
said was like yeah
they're totally um which is
or they're guilty of being accused of
being witches
which i love that because it was like
such a loophole
but they're not really guilty of like
what you guys are accusing them of i.e
like
cursing their cattle so
they basically were like trying to have
it both ways
like don't get mad at us because we're
saying they're not so we're totally
saying they're witches they're guilty of
that
but they didn't do what you said that
they did
so that seemed like a win-win for
everybody
so the two women were not uh
hanged they were actually not even
jailed although their husbands
had to pay i think 50 pounds each
for what they what the quakers used to
call a peace bond
this was this was a fascinating thing to
me
this is basically you get convicted of
something
but not bad enough to be put in jail so
basically
they're like well if you give us 50
pounds which was the case in this
trial uh 50 pounds per person it was the
husband that had to do it obviously
because he was the one that was putting
the money up and uh as i mentioned
earlier that was about
an equivalent to a thousand uh
days of jail time or you know several
pounds of hemp or whatever
so like give us 50 pounds for
six months so these ladies have to be on
their best behavior
for six months um and if they're not
i guess then i don't know they get
hanged i don't know what happens then
but it's like
they're basically like paying for these
ladies
behavior for six months and then after
that they forget about it
i guess but that was kind of like what
happened in the situation
so i feel like that was like a really
interesting
because bear in mind that this happened
nine years before the salem trials
so the fact that i'm gonna say
reason kind of prevailed even though
they gave
william penn he believed in witches i'm
not saying he didn't
but he gave like the accusers
what they were coming for without
[ __ ] up innocent women's
lives you know what i mean like so he
kind of like
had a win-win thing i feel like that was
like a really good
compromise um unfortunately
that would not happen nine years later
when the whole salem witch trials thing
happened which went full-on
[ __ ] panic mode but this seemed like
a good
like yeah they're witches but they
didn't do that [ __ ] chill out
that's funny just pay some [ __ ] money
they'll be good for six months everybody
forget about it everybody calm down
it'll be fine and i feel like had they
done that in salem
history might have been a lot different
but unfortunately
that is not what happened so like i said
i feel like
when i was reading about this it made me
kind of
it's weird because it may be kind of sad
because i was like if
if the salem [ __ ] had gone this way
and i'm not saying william i mean
william penn
being a quaker like i said they were
pacifists
they were very much into they were
christians
but they had a thing where
one one of their big things was like
they would not swear
fealty to any human person so they were
um they were very against like human
authorities like you couldn't
um be like a king you like they were
very against like swearing fealty to a
king or to any like authority figure
because they thought they
their or their only authority was god
and anybody human that tried to like
usurp that authority was like not
trustworthy
so they kind of had a their own
which you know that's cool i respect
that
so the fact that they had that might
have been some contributing factor to
him
being kind of intelligent enough
to see where this was going and not want
it to lead to something worse
so as i said he kind of came to the best
compromise that you could come to in
this situation
everyone was mad at this woman um
for allegedly i don't even want to say
allegedly cursing there can of course
she didn't do that
no one can curse someone's cattle but
everyone thought she did
so he acknowledged that people thought
that
and he's like he acknowledged okay fine
she has the reputation of being witch
without saying that she was actually a
witch
but he he was like i recognize that you
feel that
um and that's valid but
she didn't do the [ __ ] that you said
[ __ ] so that's the end of it
and i kind of like that he had the
foresight
to pronounce that verdict and it was
apparently
accepted which
i don't know like it it made me happy
but in a way like kind of sad because
like i said nine years later the whole
salem thing happened and everybody would
just forget about that example and like
just went completely batshit
and they're just like yeah whatever
everybody points their finger but
they're a witch there are which they're
which and they bring it's hanged
and that that's [ __ ] up but it just
goes to show that at least it was one
person
who even though he was he legit
did believe in witches was able to
get outside of his own ass long enough
to say yeah maybe
there's not sufficient evidence to
convict these ladies
of anything hangworthy
let's say that and i'm just gonna like
try and have it both ways
and we're just gonna try and calm
everyone down and he was like
fairly he was successful in doing that
for almost a decade
until everything went to [ __ ] later on
but i will gave
give him credit for doing that and i
will also give pennsylvania credit
because
as i said as far as i know this is the
only witchcraft trial that took place in
pennsylvania
because all the [ __ ] in salem that was
massachusetts obviously yeah although
the [ __ ] that
everybody like knows is the what like
the witch trials
that didn't happen in what is now salem
what back then was salem that's now
danvers
right massachusetts uh i don't know it
might they might have changed
i think it's danvers now i gotta say
something little green does green dust
said that they they're in there
discussing beer okay
the virtues of mexican beer and [ __ ]
you know what i mean gringo beer
and i'm gonna go ahead uh and uh agreed
with green dust for the money
yinling is [ __ ] great beer especially
that black and tan
one i love that [ __ ] black and tan
from the english
and what you do is you take a dab big
old [ __ ] glass
mug big old honky mug and you get it wet
you put it in the freezer and freeze
that [ __ ] and pour
pour a bottle of that black and tan
yenling in there
blanket is guinness though right no but
they have a yin ling mix of blood
the ending makes one too and it goes in
there and it just
almost kind of freezes into ice crystals
at the bottom
and it's thick and it's rich and it's
not real bitter but it's
it's just it's just a great beer some
some black beer is too bitter for me too
much like coffee
you know what i mean which i like but
it's good but you got to know what to do
with that
yeah there's another drink that i like i
don't know if you people know it you
know
[ __ ] some some of you i got chicanos
and i got mexicans in the damn
conversation you know what i mean and
they're all
europeans and i've got to play western
europe
there's some [ __ ] that i learned there's
some [ __ ] that i learned when i was in
massachusetts
okay and it was to take a 50 50 mix
of some kind of a black beer and and
cider hard cider which is a basically
fermented apple juice
you mix it 50 50. it's called snake bite
and you mix that into a [ __ ] frosty
mug
man that [ __ ] is good and you can get we
i would make them
make that for me here well we went to
the falcon yeah which is like a really
tiny like
indie bar yeah hopefully it's still
there because you're mixing bitter with
sweet
and they would make they didn't have a
liquor license so they could only do
beer and wine
yeah so they would do a snake bite with
guinness half guinness and half pear
cider pear cider because it didn't have
apple and it was but the pear
delicious any kind of any kind of
fermented cider
can go in there about 50 50. and
uh so you can get both bottles and mix
them in there as you do inside of a
frosty mug men that [ __ ] is so good
it was good actually [ __ ] yeah and
honestly i'm not a beer like
okay so my day out yesterday uh
in sanford we ended up going to there
are several
for some reason there are several german
restaurants
and delis in downtown sanford or at
least
two or three of them and this is a very
tiny area
so the main one that is on the main drag
which i think is called holler
box i think we were actually going to
eat there but it was too crowded there
were too many people and there were like
some kids screaming we're like yeah we
don't deal with that
so we run around the corner and there
was like a smaller one which i think is
called the willow tree
and it's a deli but they also have like
a little bit of a rusty you can get like
sandwiches and [ __ ] and they have like
this huge thing in the back where you
can pick
all these beers so my friend laura
says to me because she's been she's all
into like beers and stuff i'm not
super i'm not a beer person i'm a [ __ ]
i'm a vodka person
so i don't know a lot of beers but she
was like pointing out different ones
and she's like well she's like i'm gonna
get one so you get one like so i got one
to go with
i got like a chicken salad sandwich and
some [ __ ] cucumber salad or whatever
and i got a grapefruit beer
and it was actually really good
i don't even like no i'm into like
coffee beers i like
the vanilla stouts i like that kind of
stuff i like pumpkin beers
but i'm not a huge grapefruit fan
but i really really liked i just got a
bottle of it i got a
bottle of grapefruit very it was really
good he's good
now i got kahn jumping in there jai
you're saying you can't get drunk off
cider no you're very wrong we're not
talking about
non-alcoholic cider we're talking about
alcoholic cider
it's a fermented you can get drunk off
any of that [ __ ] if you drink enough of
it
yeah we're talking about the cider i'm
talking about
is like it is a fermented apple
cider uh it's kind of like a cross
between a wine and a beer
it's sweet it's kind of tart and it's
alcoholic
it is as alcoholic as beer you mix
that with stout or any kind of black
beer about half and half one bottle each
so you buy two bottles you get two
drinks out of it but you mix it into a
frosty mug
and you have that sweet tart mixing with
the [ __ ]
with with the um with the uh what do you
call it kind of like that
chocolatey coffee kind of kind of a
dry kind of a bitter flavor it just it
just
it works perfectly it's [ __ ] great i
tend to
call it snake bite that's what we call
it in boston snake bite
i tend to like beers that are more
coffee flavored more
chocolate flavored more like i like like
kind of richer
like earthy kind of flavors um
also like i said i kind of i tend to
like the grapefruit beer
the grapefruit beer i had yesterday was
really good
um so fruity ones are good i'm not a big
beer fan
i do like yangling um i'll drink beer if
it's available like if there's no other
other alcohol available then yeah i will
totally drink beer but
yeah yeah yeah he says he's standing
correctly they all jumped in
and said no there's another kind of
cider we're not talking about regular
we're talking a cider that's what it's
called hard cider it's alcoholic it's
the same as beer and wine
and you mix that with any kind of stout
it's just black beer it's [ __ ] sure
mix it half and half with some kind of a
black beer and it's [ __ ] great
you can also mix it with like just a
regular brown beer too it doesn't have
to be black but
black i think is the best and no you'll
[ __ ]
and the flavor is great it's looking
great
it's so weird though i'm like i'm so
used to
drinking and getting drunk and having
hangovers from
vodka generally vodka mostly
although sometimes gin sometimes
whiskey although i try to avoid whiskey
nowadays
but so i'm used to that kind of drunk
drinking beer is like a different kind
of drunk i will
occasionally get drunk off beer if we go
to someplace like i said like the falcon
that doesn't have a liquor license and
they can only do beers
so it's like it's not my preferred drink
but i will
drink enough to get drunk there and it's
like an
interesting one it makes me feel super
fat
two makes me want to pee every like 15
minutes
which doesn't usually happen with with
uh
harder lickers but it's like it's it's
interesting how it's like
it's a different kind of drunk and it's
a different kind of hangover
now green dust comes back in goes i
really need that now
the closest thing i've had to that might
be the vermont woodchuck now i don't
know what the vermont would chuck
woodchuck this sounds good though what
tell me what a vermont woodchuck says
they have yangling ice cream
no really i've never heard of that
yellow ice cream okay now
i'm now i'm intrigued yingling is
actually america's oldest brewery
that was one of our first i got into
that because of my brother
because i wasn't a big beer fan and he
was like no drink some yingling and i
ordered
one one time i'm like oh yeah that's
pretty good because every beer i'd had
before that
i wasn't into see what's funny is that
you hit you'll have like europeans talk
about american beer and they'll point to
[ __ ] like
budweiser and bush and crap like that's
not we don't like that that is not
american football well
a lot of dudes do drink that that was
massive that's
like piss water that was mass production
swell
more of like [ __ ] that you would see
from the 1950s people that know about
beer
they don't drink that now
the 1950s was an era of mass production
the world wars had ended
and they had these big corporations
trying to feed everybody and give
everybody some kind of drink of
something and they were going to do it
cheaply
in mass and that's where those companies
came from
that's not good quality it's just i mean
drinking a bud
i could drink like a whole case of
budweiser and
nothing would happen traditionally
american beer
was just like european beer it was local
breweries doing that i'm so happy
back now yeah and that's coming back but
you go back to the 1800s and early 1900s
it was local breweries just like you had
in germany
and england that's how it was done all
right it wasn't until
after the second world war you saw these
huge companies like [ __ ] budweiser
trying to give
everybody two cent piss water this [ __ ]
was nasty
but uh micro brewery beer
the closest thing to that would be
yingling yin ling was a real american
beer company you drink it that that
tastes like beer
it tastes it's like german beer like
like a stout or a hefeweizen or a vice
and beer you know just
depends on what the weird thing about
yingling is that you can't get it in
certain states you can get it here
you can but the weird thing about it is
that i don't know about nowadays
because i had my sister's
ex-husband he was from
philly and then they lived out west and
he was always
mad that he couldn't get yingling
because i guess you couldn't get it
like past it was like a [ __ ] uh
cannonball run situation
where on the other side of the
mississippi river or something like you
couldn't get it
yeah i don't know i don't know what the
like legality of it was jayer says that
so oh sorry good so every time that
he and my sister came to visit us in
florida
he would buy like cases cases of
yingling so he could take it back
because they lived in seattle they lived
in denver like for a short time
and they couldn't get it out there and
he was like really missed it because he
was from philly
so it's like you couldn't get it i don't
know about nowadays but that was like
back in the day but so because of that i
started like
because like i said i've always been
like a vicar person but
i was like well beer okay and i got kind
of into yangling and i'm like oh this is
this is okay i could get drunk off this
okay the badger comes in and says
cider and stout is a poor man's black
velvet very nice though yeah it is
it is that's bar room [ __ ] man we should
do that at the [ __ ] chair in new
england just
you're in the bar you're already drunk
you just start ordering [ __ ] well you
don't want to like
over you don't want to like black out
yeah yeah
and it's also not super gourmet or
anything
right it's it's just the work you want
something that's
reasonably priced that will give you a
buzz
but it's not gonna like wipe you out so
bad that you like
do some [ __ ] that like that you get sold
into like sexual slavery or something
like that that you don't remember
you know what i'm saying it's like you
don't want to get to that point now khan
khan in tijuana says they have a
beverage called
tapachi it's fermented pineapple that
[ __ ] sounds good and you can send that
to me oh
anybody wants to send me some tapache go
ahead and do that i'll drink that
i'll do that i don't know you can get a
joke am intrigued by
the idea of fermented pineapple yeah now
sophie's going on telling people about
angry orchard angry orchards good cider
too
it is yeah yeah i like that [ __ ] yeah
but fermented pineapple ooh
pineapple juice is one of my favorites
okay was another one that's kind of like
a cider
i think polka was made from uh cactus or
something i think whenever agave
i don't remember oh perhaps
i need i feel like i need to try more
beers
well because like i said i watch beer
and board games a lot
and they always have like these cool
sound of beers and like sometimes
they'll
like say what they are and like they'll
drink them and i was like man that
sounds really good i need to like
remember that
and like i feel like i should write it
down because some of it sounds really
good
but i never do louis chimed in said the
poke is made from agave yeah
i thought it was agave it's like an
agave cider
if i i think or an agave beer it's
fermented agave
that same thing in [ __ ] um that's
what they tequila
flavored tequila with that i mean first
weirdly i don't know like for some
reason like if i'm gonna have beer
i want a vanilla flavored beer or a
coffee flavored beer
or pumpkin beer is good too yeah cause
like i said i'm a basic [ __ ] and i love
you yeah
yeah i love pumpkin flavored [ __ ] so are
we done with the show probably
i'm hungry let's make something to eat
holy [ __ ] we've been going for four
hours yeah four hours did we even talk
about this [ __ ] case
you wrapped the case up of course you
talked about the case you wrapped it up
they didn't get hanged
yeah which is good yeah somebody
like had some [ __ ] reasonable [ __ ]
trying to say you moved off of yellow
and now you're on
red you're on level red now right well
i don't know if i'd go that far all
right this is
this is my third one yeah your third one
yeah
which is that's like a double so you've
had like six
yeah but you know yeah
my poor liver nice
all right go ahead and shut it down i
don't even see it thanks for showing up
tonight man it's good to see you guys
uh make sure you like share and
subscribe and
uh is there anything else you need to
plug jen everything buy my books
yeah buy the books [ __ ] uh
what else i don't know that's it okay
pretty much
good to see you guys we'll see you we'll
see you guys in uh tomorrow
i'm trying to like yeah we're gonna do
oh we already know what we're talking
about tomorrow because
we watched it last night okay all right
documentary
documentary yeah it was good oh yeah
documentary
about the exorcist matter of fact uh
good you can go ahead and look man these
are our friends here go ahead and give
them a heads up
uh to see that uh tell them shutter just
added
a documentary about the making the
making of the exorcist which is
essentially like an extended interview
with william friedkin yeah the director
of that it's a good it's good it's good
you guys can even see it
i was i mean i was a little inebriated
when we watched it but
yeah i i mean i'd seen
like interviews and write interviews
with william freaking before
yeah but i really liked all the [ __ ]
that he went into
like i told you while you were watching
it like all the art history [ __ ] i was
geeking out
yeah hey taylor go ahead and go go ahead
and watch uh on it's on shutter right
yes go it's called leap of faith yeah
it's called
faith leap of faith i don't know if you
used to say i'm shaking on the exorcist
exactly and we're gonna the making of
the exorcist because we just like
watched that listen
it's basically like i said it's about
how to do cinema
it's william freaking talking about the
exorcist but they also he talks about
like all his influences and he talks
about it and i was like
yeah you know filmmaking art what she
meant the soundscape how he fan
added [ __ ]
if you have if you have shutter go check
that out the making of the exorcist it's
new
i found it really good yeah they just
like i think they just put it up like
yesterday the day before yeah i found it
like [ __ ] riveting but like i said
i'm i'm
like an art history dog yeah says she's
got it yeah leap of faith go ahead and
watch that [ __ ] yeah
that's good you're gonna like it yeah
it's good i mean it's strangely relaxing
you were like relaxed and i was like
yeah yeah right tell us
and then what and how'd it go i was so
weird that's why
it's like so weird i was so into it
because he starts getting it off into
paragraph well he was
well in that like he was talking about
like caravaggio yeah
i was like dude gods and devils and uh
like
we don't know if it's real is it real we
don't really know
we don't really know anything so i just
did the movie like this
well i feel like that was kind of one of
what and i mean
you have to like william free can he
just direct the movie like
william peter blatt i like wrote the
book right so
i do feel like you have to like credit
the writer
but i think the fact that
both william peter blatty and
uh you know franken were believers
in this [ __ ] like they actually believed
that a demon could possess somebody
yeah i think that made the movie better
yeah if somebody like my [ __ ] ass had
made it
yeah it would have just been a big joke
because i don't really like believe that
can happen
but the fact that like somebody even
though she's seen paranormal [ __ ]
right but it's that's not the same thing
it's not that's not demons
or that's that's a whole different
oracle that's a whole different way at
10 000 you're not
you're not silver at 10 000 you're
bronze this bronze
and uh silver is what a hundred thousand
yeah something like that and
and youtube doesn't give out bronze
anymore that was like back in the old
days
we'd have to buy a fake we get butt kiss
now
i would buy a fake bronze and put that
[ __ ] back do you want me to buy you i
will buy you one for christmas you're
gonna buy me a fake bronze for christmas
oh but i'll make you one i'll make you a
little bronze like plaque
i imagine somebody's on youtube is
somebody making i imagine somebody's
probably on [ __ ] ebay
selling an old [ __ ] vintage well if
anybody was like smart they would do
well [ __ ] maybe
i should do that that's like an untapped
mortgage yeah
i'm sure make a fake bronze [ __ ]
plaque somebody's already thought of it
because i've seen them before they used
to look really cool but that was like a
long time
it was like 10 years ago well like i
said that was back before you had like
channels that are complete [ __ ]
like having several thousand yeah you
can buy subscribers
well the thing about it now is that i
see some channels that i
love and it's like oh they have like a
lot of subscribers and i'm like okay
that's totally justified but then i see
a couple
channels that are like [ __ ] i'm like
why wouldn't i be watching this right
and they've got like [ __ ] 40 000
subscribers like who are these people
i don't like get that who is watching
this but
whatever i i don't know what other
people's like viewing tapes are like
louie says shut it down
[ __ ] jenny stutter in her words i am
yeah okay we'll shut it down
i'm gonna shut it down i don't feel too
bad it's like four hours in sex we
we covered most of the [ __ ] like i said
nobody died in this situation
somebody's saying that that's good he's
not level red yet i can tell
i'm not level red yet last
last week last week was level red one i
didn't even like remember what the [ __ ]
i was doing
they're still back in there talking
about beer next next i'm still
i'm still takes a tangent that's what
oracle said next week's topic
topic is tom takes a tangent of course
i'm gonna take a tangent
won't know what next week's topic will
be until tomorrow
when the when the uh polls end the polls
end at noon tomorrow
if you're on patreon
if you go become a patron you like to go
a dollar to a month you will be able to
vote
on whatever our topic is and also
whatever our movie respectively for the
upcoming week so i will not know what
the topic is until tomorrow at noon when
the polls close
yeah when the polls close when the polls
all right it's good to see you guys we
got [ __ ] we got to do around here going
to make something to eat
it's good to see louie [ __ ] sophie
kahn of ozlon everybody everybody who's
here tabby was in there
we're we're gonna see you guys tomorrow
yeah bye-bye witches
witches [ __ ] go ahead right bye